hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i'm your host for today gant
and joining me once again are the boys
jesus christ sorry god damn it we had it
we had the perfect take which was the
only take we've ever done today uh you
know
outtakes on patreon.com trash taste of
course
yeah of course of course right
guys i thought we were professionals
we've been doing
the hay fever seasons we've been doing
this for almost like two years now we
should we should be on this man we
should be honest i'm sorry i'm sorry
she's got a vine boom sound effect
i've just yeah i've i've been just hay
fever's been kicking my ass this season
yeah all of a sudden i hate it yeah and
especially like now when you're
sniffling on a train and you just see
like all these like
hey yo
some japanese guys have like these
these most aggressive gravelly coughs
dude oh yeah
deep and coveted season as well you're
just like you're on high [ __ ] alert
yeah i'm like one of those guards no
gear solid and like
i actually saw uh at my local bookstore
they they were selling these pins during
the pandemic like yeah in the middle of
the pandemic that just said like during
a hay fever season it was a pin that
just said don't worry i have hay fever
[Music]
and so like people would like if they
were sniffling on the train you just
like show off the badge and be like i
don't have covered guys
but what if you had covered and you
bought that anyway just to be like guys
it's haphy
trust yeah what if you had both yeah
like because i remember
because um
i also had like a little bit of hay
fever but also i remember one week i
just got like a cough or something and
getting a cough during the pandemic time
it's like the worst right because
normally normally it feels bad
to cough in public anyway but like
you're you're like when you have like
just it's just like a dry cough
especially you have to like just you're
so conscious about it right yeah about
like how often you're coughing and it
just makes the cough like when you're
thinking about it it just makes the
cough 10 times worse you know what i
mean yeah and like especially on like
public transport you just i i remember
like normally
normally going going to my old place it
would be stressful if i needed to take a
[ __ ] right
you know when you're like holding it in
i was like holding in this like this
[ __ ] cough and like [ __ ] like
spacing this cough out that i had for
like a good 40 minutes or however long
that journey was yeah and i don't know
if anyone around me like noticed it but
i was like
i don't know i was just i was [ __ ]
sweating from like how much i was trying
to hold in this i thought i thought you
were like holding in the cough because
you didn't want to like [ __ ] yourself in
the process
who cares what are they gonna do like
it's not like a zombie apocalypse right
if you've been bitten they're gonna kill
you have you ever coughed and [ __ ] at
the same time no mine's fine
no
we're not talking about [ __ ] yet
yeah twitter
leave it for the video
no
just curious
i don't know just you've never done that
of course i've done it okay i've never
i have also we've all done it we haven't
all done that
i have never done that unfortunately
joey yeah i'm so sorry i'm sorry
it's a
i'm not asking you to be like have you
shat yourself before yeah in public like
i think before i shut myself off we've
talked about that yeah but uh yeah no
just like on the toilet and you just
like it's not coming out and then you
use the power of the cough to like
exhaust your body
so you're heavy
this is how you get hemorrhoids
i think the only thing that comes close
that isn't like [ __ ] yourself but
like it's it's when you go back to the
gym for the first time in ages you have
like ab day or something and like the
day after your entire body aches and
like the one time you sneeze it just
like puts your entire body into like
pain mode
i literally did this like two weeks ago
yeah i was an ab day for the first time
in months
not one day it was like five days
afterwards right oh really yeah why was
it lagging i did no it's in like for the
next five days oh like in a row oh yeah
i see i see because then you went hard i
i just went too hard man i just went too
hard i don't know what can i say update
what are you doing yeah talking about
seasons though like can japan chill with
its changing of seasons
um i i don't know like
it last week it felt like winter it felt
like it was coming on the like tail of
the winter it was like warming up a
little bit yeah and i think we had two
days of spring like spring weather and i
remember like going out yesterday or the
day before in this jacket and i was
sweating my ass off already
and i just like
japan i've just noticed it just it
doesn't have a transition period you
just wake up one day and it's a new
season they say japan has four seasons
what a lot of [ __ ] it's such a lot japan
has two seasons
it is two yeah it's winter in summer
that's all they have it's it's it's like
different stages of cold and then just
different stages of hot there's no
warm there's there's no like warm period
they get like the warm period is maybe
like in the evening when like the sun's
just gone down and like the the residue
of like the concrete heat is like
escaping that's when it's like okay
that's kind of pleasant but then
immediately afterwards it's just like oh
now it's cold as [ __ ] because you're in
a t-shirt like an idiot i always forget
how hot it is until the summer comes and
then i'm like oh yeah this is this is
hell yeah i think it's like trauma for
me yeah like i like i like forget about
it and yeah i'm like what some of what
i'm winter game i'm wearing i'm wearing
a coat
and i forget that for half the year in
japan you just can't wear more than one
t-shirt yeah yeah exactly unless you're
a japanese person and you can wear like
a suit yeah
yeah and it'd be like oh it's a little
little dab of sweat right here what
temperature is in the office can we have
30 degrees celsius please what yeah i
don't know like i don't know how i walk
around in the summer and just see like
business people in full-on suits carrick
was like running along with that
briefcase and i'm here dying in my
t-shirts and shorts yeah i'm a sweater
i'm a big sweater boy i am i am like a
[ __ ] i am it's it's
i mean like i'm the complete opposite of
sydney because she doesn't sweat enough
when it comes to heat like i'd like
we're deep in summer and like feel her
forehead and it's just like there's
there's zero there's zero perspiration
the same i'm like that's that's how you
get heat stroke
my body's working yeah if you sweat a
lot that's healthy
yeah technically what is it but like
it's just what do i get i mean i mean i
mean
yeah
to me it's like it's a copium like it's
it's healthy it's healthy because like
i i feel like the tiniest bit of heat
and my armpits especially just a lot
just just start perspirating and there's
no way
like and like there's no way you don't
that doesn't ruin anything you [ __ ]
wear unfortunately so i just have to
like be worried in the summer even if
i'm not even if
even if i'm like underneath air
conditioning i still sweat sometimes i
mean it's weird i don't sweat through my
armpits as much for me it's all in the
face which is horrible because you can't
hide that [ __ ] you're literally like
that meme of that guy i don't know he's
like on the radio he's like
yes
i'm like that key and peel gift where
it's just like
wet
but like the rest of my body is okay i
hate it
but yeah i mean i guess that's why we're
from from england right i mean do you
feel like being british has conditioned
you to like cold weather or do you feel
like you've gotten used to like
other climates i think it's the
temperature it's more so the sun i think
we're yeah i'm allergic to the sun
that's definitely is that because you're
white yeah i know very wide very white
very white indeed but like you know but
i i would understand because you know
you guys have like that lack of sun
right in the uk but like in australia we
have like an overdose of sun so i'm like
i'm like also traumatized by too much
sun yeah as well because in japan it's
like you know sometimes the sun works
and then sometimes it works overtime i
still think the summer was worse in the
uk than it was in japan because we don't
have a we don't have ac
it's like three four weeks of like
at least the last time i was there yeah
it was like three four weeks of just
uncomfortable sweating and now i can't
do anything yeah it's like
at least in japan i'm i can game all day
and a comfortable ac yeah climate room
right it's not yeah okay when i go
outside it sucks i i sweat but like i
take that over having a be in my bedroom
sweating and being able to do nothing
sure like it's it's horrible like you
get one of those fans that blows air but
i feel like that's literally like a
copium like machine yeah yeah it doesn't
do anything you just pull the air around
it's just blowing the hot air into my
face actually i actually like the fan
like sometimes i think that's the
southeast asia i think it is i think
people like they love fans they're like
they i swear they're just like fans all
the time so to me you're like you you
admit defeat
if you are putting on the ac right that
that means you are more weak than the
weather
i don't know like the fan like i like
the feeling of like just hot like not
exactly cold out you say you're a fan
[ __ ] off joe [ __ ] off i don't know
because like to me the ac it just feels
like how can i put this it feels like
artificial air i get it i i is
air is like not one you want to be like
breathing in i don't know why it feels
weird because it i feel the same way
about like heaters right where if you if
you have if there's a difference in
having like a warm room and having a
room that's been warmed up by a heater
right because it feels ten times more
stuffy for some reason oh yeah um like i
i don't like the feeling of just the
artificial heat as opposed to just being
in a country or in a temperature that is
comfortable like naturally outside same
thing with ac for me with ac if you get
if you have a room that's cooled with ac
it just feels
i don't know like the air how can i
describe this it feels like it feels
sterile
you know what i mean you know what i
mean
it feels it feels sterile it is first of
all problems but i agree i agree like it
just like i breathe within it's just
unnaturally dry
sometimes like my my asthma like my my
lungs feel the dry air way more with ac
air than uh than with like just cold air
in general i don't know it's
it's it's completely something that is
just a me issue but i might that's why i
much prefer having a fan as opposed to
having the ac right did i talk about why
my apartment smelled like [ __ ] for like
the first two months
your current apartment yeah why not oh
yeah
like literal [ __ ] or like literal [ __ ]
yeah so
i you know i moved into this park
building and i like i something just
kept smelling weird i couldn't put my
finger on it right and i'm not wondering
the [ __ ] is this thing i turned the ac
off right it's still coming in my
apartment still smells like [ __ ] this is
a brand brand new i just got this place
why does it smell of [ __ ] it's not me
i'm i'm definitely flashing looks down
like covered in [ __ ] i'm i'm i thought
but like it's not that kind of it's like
a lingering like yeah yeah i am i i'm
i'm getting this right so
i go to my balcony right and there's
like bird [ __ ] and i'm like well it
can't be there because i clean it
and and it and it still smells like [ __ ]
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
why does it smell of [ __ ]
turns out
that there was one place where these
birds were [ __ ]
that was like the intake fan was right
here and all the birds were just
[ __ ]
right next to the intake
and i couldn't see it because it's like
it's like right next like there's this
much gap between the roof and the box
they're [ __ ] yeah
it's literal perfect size for one pigeon
to fit in yeah and they loved loved
[ __ ] there i don't know why they
loved it maybe because they they felt
like the roof was closed you basically
were huffing and burning literally for
two months was just huffing in and i'm
pretty sure that like pigeon poop is
like one of the poops you don't want to
be breathing in i think any proof i
don't want to breathe
to be honest as in i think they have
like one of the more
dirty
poops out there i believe uh i don't
know if it's correct
uh but let's say you compared to one
compared to what listen if i laid a log
there it's
it's not going to spread is there a poop
scale of like hygiene quality
i think it's i think it's just like all
poop right surely
like cleaning pigeon poop there's a
bunch of things that like warning please
make sure you don't actually touch the
poop because it it's like filled with
like disgusting parasites and stuff when
isn't it filled with disgusting germs no
i play with mine all the time and it's
not that bad
i could have been just a generic warning
anyway so i i cleaned it and then i was
like great this is amazing it's all
fixed my family doesn't smell of [ __ ]
two days later i start smelling [ __ ]
again they just kept coming back so
i then had to install like those spikes
on it oh yeah yeah to get rid of it and
finally now my apartment doesn't smell
of [ __ ] unless i leave the door open and
take a [ __ ] then it does smell
i was gonna i was gonna ask how you've
sorted the problem because like my
apartment is a my balcony is like a joke
it's like half reflective now i've put
reflective stuff everywhere and it
doesn't stop them
yeah because i i i noticed that because
uh in in my house and in my home in
thailand it's like on the outskirts of
the city so it's more next like nature's
the nature side of things and i noticed
the spikes do [ __ ] nothing man that
the spikes the spikes is a great place
for birds to start a nest so like really
yeah these are like comically large
spikes okay okay okay i literally don't
get any birds on my balcony you're so
lucky how does that work i don't know
how do pigeons decide
this is the building that i'm gonna [ __ ]
up
maybe one pigeon is like oi
check it out yeah because sometimes we
come on come on sometimes we get like
that one [ __ ] pigeon that's hanging
out outside the toilet yeah this office
and i can [ __ ] hear it because i
don't know why like
it's like it's here and in thailand as
well
the first thing i hear when i wake up is
just these birds going at each other
like it's it's it's not even that right
it's not even pigeons sometimes it's
just like sometimes it's i i swear she's
just like
like the [ __ ] get over the birds
right and i can just hear like oh oil
mate what are you doing here what are
you doing here man
bruv bruv what are you doing i'm just
like
every [ __ ] morning i don't know what
it is
um and we so we installed spikes to try
and stop these birds from like hanging
out outside like stop them loitering
yeah stop the use of loitering outside
of some of these spikes you were using
i was just like the plastic spikes it's
just like it's just like that maybe it's
plastic and they just didn't do anything
i know but like we thought okay we're
gonna we're gonna install them to stop
the birds like hanging out here every
morning uh it did the entire [ __ ]
opposite because now they they like
found out that spikes are great for
propping up a nest there so they just
they just be on a nest there so we we
literally helped them settle down at
that point you just gotta give him
credit that's just that's just
impressive
so big brain
um so yeah unfortunately i'd rather the
birds though cause like in australia we
i would wake up to just like possums
[ __ ] on our roof what does that sound
like it just sounds it's just like a lot
of like rattling like this and a lot of
like
and like at like two in the morning i'm
like oh my god please stop that sounds
pretty good no it's not how does that
sound good
do they make a mess i hope not well if
you if you hope no that means you don't
know right so that means they probably
don't make it i mean the mess is like
half of the problem it's the fact that i
can't get to sleep because of these
problems
i'd rather have trouble sleeping than
have to clean this [ __ ] up every like
two months yeah i just
it's awful like they [ __ ] on my ikea
furniture as well it's like oh because
you got furniture on your
balcony as well so
wherever i put like the reflective stuff
down
they just move
and then i put like the reflective stuff
right above what is the reflective stuff
it's like uh like cds what's those um
are the the colososcopes what are they
called kaleidoscopes that's it sorry
the kaleidoscopes like kind of patterns
that reflect
and it just scares them off yeah but
sometimes it doesn't but some and then
other times they just like it's like
they're edging they'll like find a spot
and they'll have one foot on and they'll
just start [ __ ] off of it and i'm
like how am i supposed to predict this
this is insane that was a different very
different edging to uh
i was like
the pictures are doing what they're
probably answering
they're probably doing that as well
direct eye contact
it's awful it's awful and they like they
should they oh
it's such a pain in the ass
yeah because
do you ever have to deal like with like
annoying wildlife in the uk no
i feel like the most have any wildlife
in the uk i feel like okay the most
annoying thing for me in the uk is i
don't know if you have it in wales uh
but in the city in brighton at least or
at least when i was living in london as
well
foxes the sound that they make sometimes
at night just is like the
like is the worst screech i've ever
heard
yeah we do have fox yeah it's a deadly
sound what we have yeah the [ __ ]
[ __ ] though yeah because like
you make like eye contact with them they
run they're already like down the road
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah legging it down
a minute yeah i used to live above uh
like a bunch of restaurants so i always
saw foxes but they never made noise
they never made noise not actually
they'd never make noise if they're in
the vicinity of like guys or humans but
like for some you i would sometimes hear
them just like screeching off in like
the background and they literally sound
like i know like a kid being assaulted
or something right because i remember
the first time sydney like moved to
england she heard this noise and she was
about to phone the police i was like no
sydney that that's just a fox because it
just sounds like at least
like you just heard that in the
background right and i'm just like the
first time i heard it i was like what is
that noise at least that's what they
told you
it's just the door with like plastic
gloves on there it's the foxes it's the
foxes yeah
yeah i don't know we only had ends get
hands
that would get into the house they're
pretty good ants are they're really good
at getting into your house yeah yeah but
they're like british ants are tiny
though like [ __ ]
can they even be called ants
when there's a lot of them yeah but like
that's the problem with it
you're in the restaurant don't travel
solo they don't like [ __ ] witnesses
they're not like you don't see a single
land in your house and you're like oh
[ __ ]
they're normally like they're very kind
their ants they they have a nice line
that directs you to exactly where they
came from they're really really
considerate in that sense but they get
into like the bread bin and stuff and
they'd get into like yeah yeah like the
sugar yeah
[Music]
yeah
yeah
like you think you've like sealed that
bread box up like tight i can't find
where the snacks are hidden in my house
sometimes yeah so i have to follow the
trailer my parents just hide them but
the answer would always find them they'd
always they'd always leave i'd never
really had such a big ad problem in the
uk it was more when i was in thailand
where you live yeah yeah because like
when i was whenever i'm in thailand if
you have like a piece of food out or you
drop like a tiny bit of crumb or
something there's like a timer starts
right before you you have that time the
timer starts before you can clean it up
otherwise the ants are going to clean up
for you and then you just kind of a line
of ants just marching through your home
yeah and like the thing about thai ants
is that they're the fruit they're pretty
[ __ ] big as well i'd rather than be
big though easier to kill
no no no you know
it's like a super villain you know when
you step on an end yeah and it doesn't
die and you're like what this is how
like the villains feel the movies from
their hand doesn't
what do you mean my attack fails
but like in in the uk like ants are just
a slight annoyance because what the [ __ ]
can they do to you right they're just
like eat your food like make it like
yeah slight annoyance it's a slight
annoyance that's very big annoyance
right like like they don't bite you or
anything like something i'd rather than
bite me than take my food
really you sure have you ever been
bitten by an animal
yeah yeah i don't think you'll say the
same way
i'm not like the [ __ ] what's that guy
called on youtube coyote peterson not
those kind of ants where he's like he's
like while my hand is swollen and 19
times the original size i could scarcely
breathe
this is mildly painful even if it's
something like you know even if it's not
like toxic or like it's super painful
it's that is that is more of an
annoyance than the ants no i know if it
was a mild pain i'd rather that than
have to like what if it's like a lot of
mild pains because it's like a lot lots
of miles a lot of mild a lot of mild
people what does that mean i don't know
what's because you're not going to get
here can you give me an example of a lot
of mild pain well because you know there
is
can you give me another example because
you're not gonna because when an ant
bites you that just invites the other
ants to also attack what's going on i'm
gonna give them a second chance like
you never know
what is
put them on my nipples please bite me
again
you have to deal with any annoying pests
in australia
require me yeah when you're getting the
border like oh i made do you mind if the
koala boats on your toe mate
i don't even think i've ever seen a
koala in the wild dude i want to see a
koala they're extremely rare in the wild
because they're so hidden but like uh my
house we used to have these like wasps
that flow around all the time um [ __ ]
how did you get rid of wasps you don't
like the last time i went home i
remember i was like my dad was like you
know son come and join me for a beer on
the in the balcony it's a nice stand i'm
like yeah sure i walk out and there's
like 20 wasps just flying around because
i was like uh father what there are a
lot of wasps flying around your face
right now and he's like yeah it's all
right that won't sting you i was like
okay
why do wasps exist like like do they do
anything good for anyone no
they are the they're the [ __ ] of
the internet
it's about so many creatures though but
like so a lot of creatures don't
actively try to like be [ __ ] and
sting you and like the thing is at least
are you judging an animal's worth based
on how annoying it is to people kind of
kind of yeah yeah okay
like what what what do wasps do for
nature because you know like bees they
make honey they pollenize flowers and
you know what at least nature had the
decency to nerf bees you know they they
get one shot one shot that's like that's
like their nuclear option man that's
like they're fighting
they can't reach the shelves i desire
i would be i would gladly be racist
towards wasps
all right well that's an out of context
i would like to be racist cut
no because uh yeah god's the kind of guy
where if you go to death note the first
thing he'd write is what what's this
everyone everything that annoys
everybody like a one by one one by one
by name every single one like a simple
one for like the death note it comes
back it's like sorry did not did not
spell correctly yeah i should preface i
actually have a phobia of bees and wasps
i don't know if i've ever thought you
could have told it okay you're stung in
the eye as a kid yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah i would i would have yeah
but the thing is the thing is like i've
grown like even though i like i'm
[ __ ] deadly scared of them i still in
my heart i still i still understand why
bees you know why bees are a thing i
think i think you know after after years
of conditioning like bumble bees they
look really kind of cute like they look
like like flurry and big and they
pollenize they're chonky yeah they're
chunkier
oh just give them a hug
have you have you taken any steps
towards trying to conquer your fear of
beings
um
we do like a fear fact dress kind of
thing where we have what would the steps
be though why don't we play dark souls
music right like
and then we bring up and gone your
punishment for the trash taste after
dark is that you have to put your head
in a box of bees
what was this fear factor
would you do that
if you told me if you told me if okay
here's the thing right i'm an idiot if
some guy came on he's probably he's
always australian because on every
single wildlife show where there's a
wildlife expert the [ __ ] is always
australian of course yeah he'll come on
and be like oh yeah they won't sting you
and then the 10 seconds later you're
like
you're like oh you're fine though you're
fine
you're gonna die don't worry yeah it
changes oh you won't die yeah yeah if if
uh if some wildlife expert told me that
it's safe to do it i'd do it
stick your head in the box
that's a big [ __ ] stuff i mean like
i don't know i don't know how much for
you to put your hand in a box of bees
how much how long how much are you
willing to pay me one minute one minute
one minute
uh what is the minimum price you'd do it
for 10.
i would gladly do it for like five
five yeah five five g's five g's yeah
ten g for me i don't know it would have
to be more than ten for me
i don't know maybe or maybe or maybe or
maybe just for content
[Laughter]
oh yeah
when you're back sweet advertising if
i'm just chilling in my living room and
you can't much you put your hand in the
box
and then they do it but if it's for
content i probably do it for free i mean
here's the thing right because before
like when i was a kid i couldn't even
look at like this i couldn't even look
at videos of bees like i'd see a bee and
i'd literally scream and like run inside
and like shut so we got yeah a box of
bees you would do it for content
how do we get how do they get a box
maybe how do they do you make an
audience
how do they do this on shows how do they
get a box of but like now what like i go
through phases where like maybe like out
of like a sense of like morbid curiosity
i like look at i look at bee cleaning or
like b videos on youtube right just
seeing like these beekeepers just
[ __ ] like scooping up like these pile
of bees yeah and just them casually
being like oh you know they're very
friendly today i've only been sung three
times like you've been stung three times
and that's it that's it i'd be [ __ ]
one time is more than more than enough
for me i wonder how many times would you
get stung if your hand was in that box
for a minute like a hundred bees i think
if you just stay still nothing probably
nothing
but if you're [ __ ] doing this yeah
yeah yeah this is uh
ignorant wolf uh what is it uh ignorance
yeah wolf legendary yeah but like
okay
bees maybe because uh bees maybe wasps
get the [ __ ] out i'm coming here with a
flamethrower
if you if you come here with wasps
because like like i thought how about we
put your hand in a box with a feral
hyena gun what do you have for a minute
one minute
for content
i know it's like i've also like been
glad have you ever seen a hornet as well
yeah um those are [ __ ] like
terrifying i think i've seen we have the
killer hornets here they have to kill a
horse yeah those are those i don't want
to [ __ ] with those those are scary those
are scary yeah especially like i
remember seeing the video of just like
hornet like
it sounds like a [ __ ] it sounds like
a [ __ ] anime fight or something it's
like hornets versus bees and this video
is epic
where the beast like surround it yeah
the beasts around it and like it's it's
not it's not even like a war it's a
massacre right because the hornet like
one hornets take takes down like [ __ ]
a hundred bees or something and it's
it's i feel like oh no the beast [ __ ] up
the hornet oh really yeah we've seen
different videos then because i've seen
from fights
i don't know which b it is but there's
videos where like there is a way that
they kill the hornet by
basically they all just compact
themselves on the hornet right and
they roll around and they do it like
with like such like energy that it
actually just burns the hornet alive
well like through friction yeah it like
kills the hornet by being so hot holy
[ __ ] that's that's [ __ ] metal
japanese japanese honeybees
they kill the japanese like they
surround it and they compact like a ball
and they roll and like keep like
suffocating it and wanting it the [ __ ]
it's so bad
i'm sure there'll be a clip on the
screen right now it's it's [ __ ] cool
it's so cool like nature a lot of times
it's just sounds like you're shown in
like
i just like love it that these bees
figured this out yeah they're like [ __ ]
it just throw it how did the bees figure
that i don't know right [ __ ] now you
ever heard of friction
i could use that yeah because like the
only video i've seen is where like it's
it's just these bees like this hive of
bees just [ __ ] chilling making honey
and then these [ __ ] group of ten
hornets or something just come on and
start like [ __ ] biting their heads
off massacre this entire hive and then
[ __ ] off i'm like jesus christ
we are like [ __ ] nature can be
[ __ ] metal sometimes because i
remember seeing this video not about
bees well i think it was like ants and
scientists would just were like would
they they were
studying fire ants because fire ants
have a way when they're moving in a
group or have
they they have
how i how can i word this when they're
what would you call like a group of ants
a colony like yeah a colony of ants the
way they
act and behave sometimes can
behave like a liquid and sometimes can
behave like a solid this is yes certain
ants i think not all yeah not all of
them i think
it was fire ants they can like cross
water by yeah bunching together yeah
and basically becoming kind of like a
pseudo-solid yeah okay and then they
like kind of like yeah so they can have
they like these ants can
have as a colony have properties of a
liquid or a solid
depending on the situation so dope and
they were like scientists was
literally studying them to try and apply
this to like real life metals and real
life real life applications right just
like that that sounds so [ __ ] humans
become liquid if we try harder
i'm soul enjoy now soon i'll be a liquid
joey
i am i am solid joey but no yeah that's
yeah that's the weird nature videos i've
seen every now and again i've
uh did you guys watch a lot of nature
videos oh yeah i [ __ ] love nature
documentaries i think yeah i grew up
watching like because they used to just
do like constant reruns of like every
like david attenborough documentary so i
suppose in [ __ ] uh australia oh yeah
we
love that [ __ ] go outside and you'll see
your local kangaroo fighting come on
there now now the only kangaroo club was
the one where the guy punched the
kangaroo in the face
that one was all over australian use for
like two months
always like saving what's that about
what's that like he was uh the kangaroo
was like kangaroo had the dog yeah he
had his dog in like a in a grip and like
a vice grip how does that happen i don't
know the clip literally starts with the
guy in his truck
like just calling out to the dog being
like oh no [ __ ] terry whatever the
[ __ ] his name was i remember what it was
and he jumps out and like the camera
pans over and this red kangaroo like
[ __ ] you know
[ __ ] standing like two meters
tall just has the dog in like a grip
like this and the dog's just like
help me
it has the most like help face that i've
ever seen
and he squares up
and the kangaroo is [ __ ] squaring up
and and that's really dangerous because
like you know one kick from this red
kangaroo like in the chest that dude is
dead yeah 100 right um but no this guy's
like the biggest mega chat on the planet
which just goes whack it just sucks him
in the face and the kangaroo is like
what the [ __ ]
he looks around he's like
nah he just jumps away
and he saves the dog but like i think as
well like the the kangaroo felt
threatened by the dog i think so like
the kangaroo also tried to like kick the
dog as well so the dog could have died
too what do kangaroos eat what are they
grass
are they herbivores yeah
but they're also very very [ __ ]
strong for herbivores but they're also
extremely territorial
is the is the picture i've seen of like
jacked kangaroos is that photoshop or is
that like real i could never tell if it
i've seen it in memes some of them are
real and i'm sure some of them are like
overdone but like red kangaroos which
are like the biggest breed of kangaroos
like they like on average stand like two
meters tall [ __ ] i mean australia is
like the most interesting wildlife yeah
i mean that's because it was like a it
was pangaead
on its own for like hundreds of
thousands of years yeah so all these
weird animals that was like one of the
first ones to like break off yeah so
it's had hundreds of thousands of years
but that's also why it's also like super
delicate and why yeah when they
introduced foreign pests it like
completely [ __ ] up australia yeah like
they have a rabbit problem you know but
do you know about this yeah yeah
but they can't kill the rabbits you know
why why because people don't want them
to kill the rabbits but the rabbits are
literally killing everything everyone's
like what the bunnies are so cute though
and farmers are like uh yeah they
they like eat everything and there's
nothing left for like the you know the
because rabbits are like insane they're
like so good at like taking everything
yeah and [ __ ] i mean like the british
yeah yeah yeah
they literally well i think it was
brought over by a british guy of course
it was because the guys wanted to hunt
rabbits in australia australia so he
brought over some rabbits i could be
incorrect on this and obviously rabbits
are like very very good at expanding
yeah and so yeah they have they have
this problem and they've been trying to
they had a they were gonna start culling
them
and getting rid of them but obviously
trying to pass a a a thing saying hey
we're gonna murder a million plus
rabbits is that cool with everyone a lot
of people are like no rabbits are so
cute we can't get rid of rabbits but
it's like but it's like but our wildlife
is but but rabbits are cute it looks
like a really interesting question of
like is it you know obviously just
because it's cute
at which point do you count something as
a pest that needs
control well i think when it's actively
when it's like actively [ __ ] up the
the natural world yeah that's the
problem is that like the
delicate ecosystem that australia has
because it's so susceptible to
pests and stuff
i think
the rabbit which like went crazy and so
many of the the natural um
what does it [ __ ] up what did the
rabbits [ __ ] up well they eat everything
they take everything because we eat all
the food that the natural like animals
are right rabbits
are only like
as first from what i understand like
they
are only limited by how much food
they're using yeah they they can breed
and make as many of themselves they need
to it's just is there enough food
available and they're really good at
getting it as well so like the what are
those [ __ ] tiny rats with big ears
and a tail in australia oh bilby's yeah
like those things eat [ __ ] compared to
the rabbits the rabbits like absolutely
cream them and everything
and also rabbits like rabbits eat their
own babies
do they yeah
google do they actually do they that's
metal as [ __ ]
like rabbits don't give a [ __ ]
like everyone's like oh rabbits are so
cute rabbits eat their [ __ ] babies
bro well you're gonna call something
cute when it's like devouring its
firstborn child like it's like
this one i could just make another one i
mean
yeah sometimes yeah but but like
the fact that that's even an option is
like nice i mean let's be honest humans
are let's let's pretend like humans
haven't done it all right we're not
great we're not if we judge the whole
species by one or two rogue rabbits
okay the one thing that doesn't make
sense to me i guess okay is okay rabbits
are [ __ ] thriving in australia
they're like beating the [ __ ] out of
australian wildlife yeah why is it not
why isn't our problem in the uk
well because you guys don't have enough
native animals well rabbit rabbits are
as far as i understand they're native to
the uk yeah so
the whole
like ecosystem in the uk
had been created right with rabbits
being in it for a very long time yeah if
i'm correct can you google this
yeah you need to have the balance right
right and i just i'm just finding it
funny that rabbits can survive [ __ ]
australia where you look at a spider
wrong and you're [ __ ] well i mean
like in the uk
in the uk foxes are like the biggest
[ __ ] of the animal kingdom
australia has a lot of species
that
are like it's like the you know you're
playing on the the easy server you know
if
it's like a lot of these even though we
know australia is like one of these
super scary animals with these snakes
and stuff they have a lot of species of
animals that can only survive in
australia yeah yeah and it's very
delicate well like koalas for example
only eat eucalyptus and a specific type
of eucalyptus that's grown in only in
australia natively yeah so that's why
you don't see koalas in the wildlife
outside anywhere else because they
literally can't survive yeah like in any
other continent like the animal probably
wouldn't have evolved to just eat one
type of plant that is very
not popular yeah you know what i mean
like you would have to adapt gonzo
yeah so
okay but in australia
species there's a problem like why these
obviously people don't understand this
in like the 1900s yeah we didn't [ __ ]
know what's going on they were like just
bring my pets over and surely it'll be
fine
what i understand is the the argument of
why we shouldn't be getting rid of these
rabbits it's like oh they're so cute
though meanwhile when the australian
government was like eat the kangaroos
right now no one was like but they're so
cute okay this is also a common thing
with cats cats are more often a very big
past in places people don't want to get
rid of cats because
people have pets that yeah they have
cats
if the government is like hey you at
home are you okay with us killing all of
this animal and you look down and you
see that animal staring at you that
you've loved and named and fed and you
know what i mean it's really hard and so
what you're saying is less people need
to keep rabbits as pets
what he's saying is rabbits have way too
good pr yeah yeah that is
so there's too [ __ ] like good they're
like the mcdonald's
they've got it like
right you can tell them that mcdonald's
puts all the [ __ ] in their food it
doesn't [ __ ] matter people are gonna
eat it it's like i'm i understand both
sides and i i don't i i i empathize with
both i empathize with these poor like
these people who care about the natural
wildlife who are like we need to keep it
the way it was supposed to be i also
understand why that person with 10
rabbits at home might not want to have
all of the rabbit population culled yeah
i get both right also another fun fact
while we're on fun facts about adams go
on did you know
i love this i i was i was watching an
episode of qri the other day are they
talking about this
do you know why for the longest time
they never gave
the giant tortoise a genome like an
official genome name
why
like they could they you know how every
name every animal has a greek name oh
okay right right do you know why they
never gave the giant like turtle
name
we they knew about this animal for a
very long time right problem was these
are the [ __ ] they can live like
300 years yeah exactly
problem was
people couldn't stop eating them they
never ever made it back oh i did hear
about this yeah because every time every
time they tried to ship the tortoises
would just eat them yeah it would never
survive the journey because they were
too delicious
so
so the the the
apparently through the because we don't
eat it anymore obviously yeah
yeah because there's none left there an
endangered species now
in the writing right here's the is
literally like the perfect storm of
unfortunate for the giant tortoise
so
apparently in in the in all of the
documents left about the giant tortoise
it tastes better than any meat yeah it
tastes better than lamb it tastes better
than beef it tastes better than pork
everyone like almost unanimously agreed
who tried this meat agreed that it
tasted better than all of them right
damn i want to try this right
right
another unfortunate uh evolutional uh
part of the giant tortoise is that it
also ah this is just so sad
it evolved so that it could store up to
like one gallon or one liter of water i
can't remember which one it was yeah
yeah yeah inside of its body almost
perfectly like a sack
so when you would eat it as a human
there was almost perfectly this one
liter captured so basically it came with
a drink it came with a with a like a
meal imagine it you've just had this you
know you're you're living it's just a
survival pack yeah at the end of the day
you're living at the time where beer was
drank more than water yeah yeah water
was hot
yeah
it was it was hard to get a hold of in
in certain places so you had this animal
that tasted amazing
that was this perfect kind of like it
could store very easily it was very easy
to eat or a lot of the meat was edible
in it as well and it had this one gallon
sack of water that you could just drink
so sailors would when they would take
them back they were like well [ __ ] we're
gonna eat it
because not only was it delicious and
amazing they also had a free gallon of
water they could drink so it never made
it wait so does it have a genome now it
did it did after after many many years
it finally got one but food but it never
it never survived the journey back to
like the uk or something yeah so they
could never classify it yeah yeah
that's just so good
it's really [ __ ] up but that's
hilarious that's just like can you
imagine it just on the boat and you're
like [ __ ]
i
we're gonna bring back 10.
we're gonna eat nine we're gonna let one
go back all right we all agree one can
go back we only need one to name it
right
and then it's like one week left on the
ship and they're like
[ __ ]
dude
remember that flambe giant tortoise we
had dude
that's looking kind of delicious right
now i'm getting real parched
just makes me wonder how good most of it
must have tasted yeah they must
gonna bring 11.
the way they wrote about it was that it
was so delicious that like it it sounded
like they genuinely just like couldn't
resist eating it yeah but like imagine
it's that delicious we were like boys
defensive going for like a quick voyage
to the the
the islands to go and get some more more
giant tortoises and they just keep
eating it every time
i'd like to think it was that good they
would go back to go and get more me and
the boys
yeah it's an endangered species now
right
it's like
oh wait i thought it was just indeed we
[ __ ] up okay okay
but so it's kind of like the dodo as
well right yeah
but like i would rather was okay i'm not
i'm not i don't want us to extinct any
animal right but i would rather as
extinct animal because it's too damn
delicious
not that it's that we wanted its horn or
something that feels so wasteful if
we're like dude we made a an amazing
stew out of the giant tortoise part of
me is like that's [ __ ] up at least at
which point do you think like natural
selection just should just take its
course right right right
okay i'm just gonna
say like it's your fault for being born
this delicious i don't know i don't know
i mean
he's got a point he's got a point if
this if why the [ __ ]
this animal just was so unfortunate that
it evolved to be the perfect
like like food for humans to eat you
[ __ ] up in some way in evolution by
being super delicious right and having a
free second time
you kind of are kind of right they just
didn't survive obviously again every
part of the tortoise was also edible
camaro apparently was also delicious in
soups and stuff it was every single part
of this [ __ ] was delicious
this tortoise had evolved somehow to be
so goddamn delicious
i don't get it and i'm angry that i'm
never going to chit-chat yeah
yeah i'm angry that i'm going to try it
now as well so i mean i'm i'm more angry
that it's extinct
because i can't right now
or something all that [ __ ] but you
know
the delicious animal i mean we've talked
about eating possible dinosaurs and all
the dinosaurs we might not possibly be
able to eat you know like where's the
jurassic park episode where they bring
back a extinct animal so they can just
like serve as a delicacy right that's
all i'm saying
we bought the signs like we brought back
the t-rex we heard flambeing this [ __ ]
so yeah that's what jurassic park would
actually be it wouldn't be a it would be
a restaurant it wouldn't be a
thing
it wouldn't be a theme park it would be
like come on come on if you bring back
an extinct animals there's gonna be that
one [ __ ] he's like
me i'm gonna be there how do they taste
how do they taste come on there's got it
there's definitely gonna be a dinosaur
restaurant somewhere in the world of
course you know i mean it's the you know
the turtle it's unfortunate that it was
perfectly evolved to be yeah
to be eaten
there are some animals where i'm just
like without humans you'd be [ __ ]
you'd be on your last legs i mean laughs
we saved you you should be grateful
how did how did how did pandas become
china's like national animal right
because
is it isn't it like pandas
isn't it like they have to [ __ ] they do
not [ __ ] yeah they just refuse to
[ __ ] have offspring and [ __ ] and i'm
just like if you have an animal that
just like does anything that is possibly
could to willingly not [ __ ] breed
like at which point you were just like
maybe they just don't want us they exist
well the man is just like we just want
to die
here's the problem with us as humans
when i think it comes to us with extinct
animals yeah the amount of shits we give
about saving an animal is inherently
tied to how cute it is that is that is
such a i i i refuse to believe any other
explanation yeah do you if we if you
told us oh we have to save this one
species of uh
flounder people would be like oh we
don't know we can live without a flower
but it's delicious yeah yeah yeah
there's two things people care about is
it delicious
we are so [ __ ] biased all of the
animals we want to save are either cool
as [ __ ] or cute as [ __ ] that is true
think about it think of an animal top
the head that people are trying to help
like you see campaigns about and stuff
that where the animal isn't cute or cool
i mean i don't know how like i know
it's like the most endangered species i
know like pandas
name extinct animals
cool cool yeah cool um i mean just any
animal with good pr right that's it yeah
but but to get good pr you need to be
cute right yeah cute all like badass
like if the species of snake snake was
dying out yeah those snake people online
would
make people
you know you know who i'm talking about
but
most people wouldn't give a [ __ ] let's
be honest like you're not going to see
the like the fundraisers about it i'm
just being honest like that's how we are
we're so [ __ ] biased as humans yeah
we love to be like oh yeah save all the
animals accept the ugly ones [ __ ] them
they can die
unless they're like unless they're like
exceptionally ugly like the blob fish
where it just becomes a meme though like
now we gotta save them
[Applause]
the tooth fish and it's just a fish that
is just like literally razor blades and
like no eyes or face you're like well no
one gives a [ __ ] if it dies i mean i i
don't get me wrong i'm sure the
scientists who spend their life
researching this stuff will be very sad
but the general population doesn't care
yeah let's not pretend like we do
yeah we don't we don't no we don't we
don't we only care when it's already
happened yeah yeah i guess so i mean i
mean like i mean like animals have
animals have been going extinct for the
entire history of nature itself i'm not
saying we should just let them go
extinct no no no i'm not i'm not saying
that i'm saying like okay
i feel like this should be like i feel
like we should try to preserve nature as
much as we can of course um but you know
we're not gonna be like a weak mindset
i mean like if humans have had like a
direct effect on making this animal is
things i think yeah we should we should
take responsibility like okay yeah we
kind of [ __ ] up their entire
environment their entire habitat yeah
let's let's let's try not to do that
again unless they're delicious of course
you think rabbits have this this meaning
should we uh stop [ __ ] i actually
we're taking over a lot of things
too much
consume consume [ __ ] consume this
episode is sponsored by expressvpn
watching netflix without using
expressvpn is like buying tickets to a
taylor swift concert but only being able
to watch the opening act
as you know a lot of content on netflix
is region locked luckily we get all the
anime but i'm missing a lot of good old
british tv shows but thanks to
expressvpn that's a problem of the past
because expressvpn lets you change your
online location to wherever you want
control where you want netflix or other
streaming websites to think you're
located and boom all of those libraries
will be open to you like that i actually
use expressvpn quite often uh it's just
one tap on the app it's very easy easy
i don't know what else there is to say
it's easy you can pick any country you
want and if you you know want to change
your region for whatever reason be it
content or if you're shopping buying
tickets for stuff you know sometimes get
cheaper flights so yeah it's it's really
easy to use so what are you waiting for
be smart stop paying full prices for
stream services and only getting a
fraction of their content get your
money's worth at expressvpn.com trash
taste that's expressvpn.com
trash chase to get an extra three months
of expressvpn for free after the episode
have you ever had to like clear out
wasps invest uh infestation or whatever
yeah
sucks what what what's the process
around uh
broom and running shoes in the uk i
think you're supposed to call a
specialist yeah uh but i think a lot of
people just take matters into their own
hands
yeah we just take matters into our own
hands yeah because like i i know
um i've had to see sydney's dad deal
with like a wasp nest a wasp nest being
like just just newly formed and even
even that was just like i am standing
behind it's like six foot of bulletproof
glass while i'm watching you do this
because how do you deal with it you
shoot it yeah
just in case there is no good reason to
earn an m16
there's a wasp
yeah i have seen i'm going to shoot them
down one at a time i have seen like a
video on youtube of like americans and i
i think they were texans getting risks
of getting rid of wasps nests with a
shotgun
and it went exactly how you think it
went
oh [ __ ]
immediately come and attack yeah
no it's like is there any like [ __ ]
animals that you [ __ ] that terrify
you that you'd see and you're like
i think australia's just conditioned me
to be like as long as it doesn't kill me
i'm not really afraid of it there's
there's no like one particular animal or
bug that scares me the most but like
i mean if there's a if there's a deer or
a bear in front of me yeah i'm gonna be
scared we've already spoken about this
yeah i'm scared you know i it's not so
much me being scared of a lot of animals
it's just me being like creeped out or
cautious about them right like i'm not
i'm not scared of a cockroach yeah but
i'm not like oh yay little cockroach you
know i'm not i don't love it yeah you
know what's okay one bug not scary okay
like 50 bugs together freaks me the [ __ ]
ah
yeah i'm actually the same like i i
[ __ ] hate spiders i mean you like
only a few people don't hate spiders but
i actually prefer like the bigger the
spider is like the more comforting it is
for me because at least i can see it it
never leaves you
right it is it's it's like it's got a
shotgun
a larger kickbox
it's got like a larger box right in case
i want to do something there's [ __ ]
small spiders that scurry about those
are the ones that [ __ ]
keep me up at night and i don't know why
i don't know why it's one thing i don't
miss about the uk we had a lot of
spiders in my house in wales are they
really are any of them poisonous though
no no no just like you just don't want
to sit like when they go under your bed
and you've like lost them weak mindset
it does suck when you see a spider go
underneath your bed and you're like i'm
dead no no the worst one is when you're
sleeping and you see it on the ceiling
and you blink and it's just disappeared
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah talk about the
i've had like loads of mice and rat
problems in the uk yeah i told you about
that no
actually i think you i think i've had
rats in swansea and i had mice in london
right what's the difference between a
mouse and a rat again oh you know the
difference brad is like a huge mouse
rats are like well they're massive dude
they're [ __ ] rats are like the mega
chads okay and the mice are just like
civilians okay
that scary but mice are so fast like
rats are fast i
might move at like the [ __ ] speed of
light though and also the thing that
sucks about mice is that they can like
no gap is too small for mice sure yeah
they can fit through anything so they
would go un under the door even though
the clearance is like this they would
like squeeze underneath
they turn into a liquid form literally
literally dude i remember because we
were
this it was so funny because this uh
this masonette in london that was
created it was
being touted as being rat and mouse
proof that was the whole point behind
the building yeah and the landlord was
extremely furious when i told him about
it i was like yeah man oh we got we got
mice and he's like
what
i bought this place specifically because
i was told that it couldn't have mice
i'm like well we got mice and and and so
do you make a place mouse and rap
it's not possible i don't think it's
possible um and so
we had these uh mice and
they always came out at night i don't
know if that's normal yeah i never saw
them during the day but they're
nocturnal i don't know it was horrible
though because i'd be like in my bed
watching netflix tv's there door is here
and i just see a shadow
oh [ __ ]
in my in my room yeah i've had that
before and i was like what the [ __ ] it's
so weird we don't get mice and rats in
australia it might be too hot i don't
know well i think it's because all the
snakes are [ __ ] yeah yeah right
because they get like [ __ ] by snakes
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
and um yeah we tried all this expensive
stuff for killing them yeah in the end
the thing that killed them the most was
just um mousetrap
the basic amazon mousetrap it would clap
their chairs don't fix something that's
not broken right i think i think the i
think the poison killed some of them but
we ended up just needing to like clog it
but the thing is they chew through
everything yeah yeah yeah no matter what
you clog it with they just they they do
they get through it like and in new york
the rats can chew through concrete yeah
yeah yeah little by little right insane
it's insane
the the one pesto
yeah the one person like terrifies me of
ever getting is termites i've never
known anyone with termites oh yeah we
had termites it's not really probably
like a
yeah yeah cause like my parents place
had like a termite infestation and it
was scary because it's like oh the house
might come yeah right
like it's it's the one of the few pests
that if you have it in your house and
under the right conditions it could just
kill you right because you're just
wooden houses in australia mainly right
yes yeah so yeah yeah how do you deal
with derma it's like what's the process
around when it comes to termites you
just have to call like a specialist for
that don't they just like gas the place
pretty much they like smoke it out
basically right um yeah but like yeah we
had a termite it wasn't like a massive
infestation but we were like uh yeah we
should probably get rid of these now
because if they expand
yeah the house is going to come down
yeah like so
[ __ ] that that's [ __ ] terrible it's
so scary they're so sick that when they
do that like when they just put like gas
all in the house yeah i've seen they're
so cool or why why isn't that cool it's
like wow they just put like a tent over
the house and guess it i'm like that's
so badass who who thought like well oh
we're gonna kill these rats oh i've got
to use these uh rat poisoning guys like
hold up
boys what if we dash the whole what if
we nuke the house
the first time
someone suggested that someone must be
like you're crazy
what if we put a big ten a comically
large tent around the house it's almost
like you're a genius
let's try it
how else are they gonna get rid of like
thousands of tiny insects just living in
every single crevice they're not gonna
be like
they're gonna be like well well it's
either like the 10 or the flamethrower
and i'm like before we get the flame
throw out maybe we should try out a 10.
maybe i think the one job on earth sort
of somewhat related to this not dealing
with like getting rid of bugs and stuff
but yeah you know people who clean
houses actually people have died yeah
that's like the one job i don't think i
could do
oh it depends on how horribly they died
yeah well because normally you know when
you get older you struggle to take care
of yourself so the house gets like
really like you know
and uh i saw one in about japan it's so
depressing and it's just like no it
happens very often yeah yeah yeah and
they go in and they're just like well
we're just gonna take all these guys
possessions and uh trash them and stuff
it's like oh oh that would break my
heart dude go into someone's house
trying to figure out like what their
like life was like and stuff i couldn't
do it oh i mean i guess i mean like
bring in the trash
i thought you meant people who had like
been brutally murdered yeah
i was like yeah that's a pretty that's a
pretty good i mean that's pretty one and
part of it but like what if you're like
uh a guy who like couldn't take care of
yourself you're like 70 and uh you know
maybe you couldn't make it to the toilet
and stuff
i don't know i i feel like i feel room
smells like [ __ ] yourself oh yeah i mean
it happens like it happens yeah of
course i mean i i i think that'd be like
a fine job i mean
god say i'll do it
i mean it's not a pleasant job but i
feel like it would not freak you out
just knowing that like someone was there
like and living there like like a week
ago that'll freak me out i think you get
pretty numb to it after a while yeah i
mean i
i feel like cleaning out you know all of
their stuff you just like be like oh
this is this is someone's legacy you
know this is someone's entire life
i don't know just trying to figure out
what what happened like what was their
life like maybe they wouldn't i think
that's super interesting yeah yeah you
get you get like a peek into someone's
not saying like this is like a glorious
job or something but like i think you
know if someone died peacefully of like
old age or something and you're cleaning
their house i think that would be like a
a really interesting way to like really
like what they're like piece together
what kind of person they are and i you
know i think unfortunately in the modern
era we have this peaceful ignorance that
we think that uh a lot of deaths are
this like pleasant he passed away with
his friends and family especially like
japan and stuff it's like no like
tanaka-san died age 19 his apartment and
his family hadn't seen him in five years
and he doesn't have any friends right
and he's just skeletons and it's yeah
it's like [ __ ] happens because the
video was like following this guy that i
watched and he was cleaning it out and
it was just like he was like yep it
looks like he tried to make some food
right before he passed but he wasn't
able to and it's like oh
you mentioned heartbreaking
curry dude like we all deserve that we
all deserve just a nice before the curry
wait so how would they die then
well you know if you're getting really
old and you're not you know and you're
not able to make it to the toilet and
stuff and you can barely get out of bed
and no one's there to help you you know
it can be really [ __ ] oh yeah yeah you
know one day your heart could just be
like i don't think so and then just stop
you know yeah i mean i think there are
worse ways to pass away than that i mean
it's it's they they died in their home
and you know i i think that's that would
be something where a lot of people wish
to pass away i think i think a worse job
is like the people who have to clean up
after like train accidents yeah that
would be traumatic yeah that would like
suck us like to me if i knew a guy died
peacefully i'm you know peacefully of
old age in their own house i'm like you
know what death is never a nice thing
but if there was a way that i would want
to go it'd be like that you know just
just nice and nice and peaceful in my
own in the comfort zone you know just
like very quietly you know just like
reflecting on that person's like me well
you know it's like oh cool this guy
jumped in front of a train i have to
pick up his [ __ ] pieces of his skull
you know i was like i don't i would much
rather do the house job than the other
one yeah i know i
remember i stayed like uh i remember i
stayed like at an airbnb once
and uh the guy running this airbnb was
like this uh old japanese guy he was a
still he was like in his 70s or
something and it was like showing us you
know giving us a tour around the house
and
it's a bit morbid actually but um just
like just like one
block away from the house was like a
graveyard right and
and he uh and we had to walk through
this graveyard to get to his house right
and he uh
he pauses uh he pauses at uh at one of
the graves and he talks about oh this is
uh you know my dad's here my uh my grand
my grandad is here um and i'm gonna be
right there
and me and sydney go
oh he's prepared he's prepared cool uh
that's that's that's how did you react
to that
how did you how did you write to you i
got an old guy and being like yeah i'm
going to be there in a few years i'm
like why why not
okay you're out of nowhere but i mean he
you know like i i can't even like begin
to empathize what my thoughts would be
like at that age you know at what point
do you just accept your own mortality
and you just kind of come come come come
to terms with it and come yeah
i think it's kind of bad ass though to
be like you know just kind of
facing reality and being like you know
what i'm going to be there soon i'm just
going to enjoy life you know while i
still have it kind of thing you know
yeah he's he's pre-ordered
he pre-ordered his grace he pretty
ordered the pre-order death
he had like the space like and
everything i was just like oh it's like
to me as a young guy jimmy is like a guy
in his 30s that's like dude that's
that's a bit morbid to me but i mean i
don't know
at that age i don't know how i'd feel oh
people in japan like everything planned
out
yeah they like everything that's true i
want to know when i'm dying sorry yeah i
can figure out how many crochets i need
to do okay at which age would you ever
consider
getting life insurance right because
okay because when you get like kids
you're supposed to yeah usually or like
writing a will right
it's it's it's something you never
really think about but don't they say
that you should write a will like in
your twitter yeah i've won yeah i've
been i've been meaning to yeah like i
feel like we're at that age group where
we should have a will already okay
here's the thing i think it's when you
have something
you know if you you know we we're quite
successful we've done well yeah and so
if you have some
savings that could be of great help to
your family members or something [ __ ]
the government don't give it to them
yeah make sure you're you know in your
family who gets it yeah yeah so i think
if you have anything
worth giving to your family that is
significant you can you should do well
at any age you know god forbid something
happens but yeah yeah god god forbid
right to my sister i give my entire body
pillow collection
nothing else do not touch the bank money
who like you who am i giving my youtube
channel
i'm literally giving away clout
who wants the clout on my youtube
channel i have already decided that i
want my the reading of my will to be a
comical endeavor so i'm going to add the
most stupid items to my will and be
extremely specific with instructions
just to just to get a good laugh from
the grave
yeah i don't know because like i don't
have any brothers or sisters and i would
hope
that i pass away after my parents so and
i don't have any kids right now so at
this point i'm just like when when when
is there if that like awkward
conversation or that awkward realization
to be like i should write a will or i
should look into life insurance because
i don't know like i don't know about
your parents but uh like i remember like
a few years ago my parents told me that
they had started writing their wills and
i'm just like mom dad i don't want to
think about that right now you know
just don't tell me i don't want to like
i i acknowledge it but yeah at the same
time just i don't want to hear about it
i mean my dad just used to meme his will
all the time like growing up being like
if i ever did like a good deed my dad
would be like i'm adding that to the
will you get an extra item on my will
he's like yes
what the [ __ ]
it's like a [ __ ] competition it's
like all right who wants to who wants
the house in the world who's it gonna be
yeah cause like i've told the story of
how like i gave uh my dad like my dad
wanted like a car
yeah right and he's like son the entire
record collection that i have was to
your sister but now it's under your name
now
it was like yes i'd like to think your
dad doesn't even have a will and he's
just making videos
the same [ __ ] as he goes along
probably but yeah i i remember i read
somewhere i think it was on like a
japanese program that they recommend
that you should just write a will like
as soon as you'll just like
have awareness
pretty cheap i think any document and
then you get it witnessed i think yeah
yeah
i don't think it's that complicated is i
think it's just like going out of your
way to be like hey i'm going to write
about
the moment after i have passed away and
who gets my belongings and you know
before you think to yourself you're like
i don't have any belongings worth giving
away to begin with why would i write a
will
well my jojo collection needs to go
somewhere who would you give that to who
would you give that to would you trust
one of your family right i would trust
the boys
you'd keep onto them thank you very much
treat them well
you would definitely not recently mad
you can resell it
i better get good price it's my it's my
joke
like oh yeah i'll be honest you just
like quickly signed yeah hopefully my
name won't be like worthless at that
point maybe worth something i don't know
how do you go about like like what is
the structure of writing a will though
that's what i've always wanted to know
like do you write it like a novel or
like a letter like i think you can be
can you write out like a poem i think
you'll be as playful as you want with it
you ever thought about doing a video
will a video yeah what's up guys welcome
to my will
so i'm dead
is this that like the new youtuber
[ __ ]
trend we've had apology videos now we
just have
make sure to subscribe just kidding
you're not gonna get another video after
this you've heard of uh i made this
video five years ago and uploaded it
yeah yeah get ready for i made this
video when i was alive and that's the
way i died
i think that would be [ __ ] cool yeah
i think that would be cool
so if you're watching this video i'm
dead yeah so the payoff might not work
if like youtube like doesn't exist in
like 60 years or it's probably gonna be
like age restricted and [ __ ] banned
off youtube
imagine that imagine that someone
someone like dies of like a terminal
cancer you can you can play a video of a
dead person on youtube
well i mean it's not you know it's not
you showing the [ __ ] footage you're
dying i mean the the the it's like it's
like me now age 20 i record something
i'm like oh this is too big
not not me like bye guys boom it's like
that
i mean i mean like the only like closest
thing i could think of was like the
um the unfortunate thing of what
happened with etika um and that you know
that that got removed my youtube so i
don't know we've never had it before so
i guess we've never had like a president
before of like what would happen
these youtubers who have died and the
video's still up i think that was
especially like have has there been a
youtuber who has recorded
their like a goodbye video
oh right before they die no no like like
a goodbye video that would be uploaded
post-mortem you know does that does that
make sense without okay can i ask you a
moment question are you asking that
without the intention of then doing
something very sinister yeah without
these like like
let's say let's say they have like a
terminal illness or something and oh yes
there is there has been there it is
there was a very
it's a it's a powerful watch um i don't
think i could like i don't think it's
hard to talk
a guy was vlogging uh his um cancer
journey i forgot the name i wish i knew
the name um off by heart but
it was it's it's it's hard to watch
because yeah you know he's doing well at
some points and then it's unfortunately
it takes a turn for the worst yeah and
the last few videos he uploads are very
painful he's in like the hospice
and um oh god and uh
you know it's really you know i i think
that it's very rare that we had uh
footage of watching that but
yeah he's uh he was uploading a video
and um
yeah he unfortunately passes away but
all the videos are there and his whole
journey's there and uh it's very
inspiring but how cool is it that you
know at least you know all of that is
now documented right forever yeah and
that's just like out there for people to
watch and be inspired by like that's i
can imagine that
um
i mean yeah it's it's it's it's hard to
watch because it's just i don't think i
could yeah yeah like okay uh this is
this is going this is going on a tangent
right because we we are talking about
terminal illnesses and stuff like that i
like do you
it's do you feel like
you're watching that you know watching
something like that happen in your eyes
in front of your eyes do you feel like
with
with how
with with how awful that situation is
that seeing that kind of thing portrayed
in media so often has kind of like
desensitized or
desensitized you to like how awful that
is in reality just because you know the
you know the cancer patient or someone
dying of cancer has been like used as
such a common writing trope in like
every sad anime film
and just like every sad plot point in
general yeah yeah i mean it's it's
i guess until you experience it right
yeah like yeah and it's someone close to
you or even you know yeah with yourself
you experience it like i think it's it's
impossible to portray it and
authentically i think though just the
the sole fact that you know that trope
has been used so many times in the in in
fiction and yet it still continues to
draw emotion out of the viewer or the
listener whatever it is right like like
people like you know
stories about like oh you know the the
main character got is you know has a
terminal illness slowly dying and it
shows all of that yeah first time you
consume anything like that
99 of people will like you know be very
emotional like yeah yeah cry yeah but
it's interesting how you could watch 10
different shows like that and you'd
probably still cry in the 10th one as
well right so i think like even though
it's been overused in fiction i think
just that is so
powerful and potent enough that like
it'll just continue to like
evoke some kind of emotion let alone if
you yourself experience that [ __ ] like
that is like
that that just adds on to it i feel like
yeah yeah and i'm sure you know some
people be disadvantaged to it sure yeah
but i think at the end of the day
there's a reason why
writers still use that job i guess for
me like i went through like a weird
experience where i i had seen so many
stories like this that there was a point
where i got desensitized to the media
where i was just like oh it's it's it's
a character dime because of a terminal
illness like an and and then i i
unfortunately experienced um a family
member passing away because uh because
of something like this and it was just
like it definitely grounded me in a way
that
i never
not that i never thought i would i just
like put things into perspective for me
right and it just i don't know like
i haven't since
since that has happened i've like
actively
avoided any stories around that because
because it seems way more way more real
to me so i don't know how i would react
to that like but part of the reason for
example that
i couldn't
uh i couldn't watch clan ads right or i
couldn't finish clan hat uh was because
at the time i was watching it i just
felt like it just felt like tripod right
yeah it just felt like cry porn where
like i was like so
disconnected disconnected with with what
was happening on screen because i'm just
like you know this is
this is this is this is key just trying
to try and make me cry you know
it's trying to make me cry um but yeah i
don't know if i had a point i just like
i i don't know if i would react
differently to watching those types of
media now that i have grown up and i
have more experience about
more experience about you know the real
events that i guess influence stories
like this
um and if i would still feel the same
way or if i would still be desensitized
because it is a fictional story that uh
that has been told many many many times
i think when it gets to that point
though it just revolves around how
well
written like that's the story that's
true because there are so many stories
where they use that trope but you're
just like
okay i'm i know i'm supposed to feel sad
for this character right now but the
writing is so mediocre that it hasn't
given me enough emotional storage for me
to care about this character that's true
i think it's like impossible to
replicate the feeling of going through
it in real life just because like no
matter how good the writing is because
you know you're talking about something
that let's say it's a movie yeah tries
to do it in two hours yeah what would
take essentially like a lifetime to
build up yeah yeah like the reason it's
so
crippling in real life and it hurts so
much is because if it's like your friend
and then it happens at 20. yeah it's
like we have 20 years of being their
friend yeah
and now it feels like it's it's being
like robbed yeah yeah so i feel like
it's almost impossible to portray it in
a way that will give you the same
emotion i think it can give you a sense
of empathy
in a in a very deep way but nowhere
nowhere near can it like compare to the
feeling that you might feel if you go
through it i think yeah well i think one
of
the biggest not issues but one of the
biggest hurdles between like
communicating your experiences to an
audience member or to someone who hasn't
experienced the same thing as you is
that there is like such a massive
difference between sympathy and empathy
like they'll be like there'll there'll
be people i talk to and they talk about
their experiences and i can definitely
sympathize with the emotion that they're
feeling but there's also there's also
like
do you guys ever feel like a connection
with someone who has actually shared the
same experience with you like like the
same emotional experience with you then
there's like there's a connection there
when you share that experience that
cannot be replicated no matter
how much other people try to understand
you and try to understand your feelings
and everything like that
there is a feeling that cannot be
replicated
without the same empathy and
um
and i know there's to me there's
something special about being able to
communicate that empathy
through through like fictional media
right because there are there are some
times where i watch a film
um and i feel something that's not just
hey you should you should cry or you
should feel this because this character
went through that it's wow i really feel
like an actual connection with the
creator now because he's portraying an
emotion that i know
is impossible to depict unless you have
been through that exact
experience yeah and i'm trying to feel
i'm trying to think of when was the
latest time
when was the latest time i mean off the
top of my head i i think of like
evangelion right
and like why
why that
uh why why i have such a close emotional
connection to that and it's it's like
it's so weird for me with ava because
i've watched ava in several several
stages of my life and
the the reason it's the most important
for me was because there was a point
where i felt like i was going through
the exact same emotions the creator was
and
this is going on like a complete [ __ ]
tangent by the way
and yeah i i guess to me that's why
going on a different and going on
different hand that's why media is like
such a big such a big part of my life
and why i'm a [ __ ] anime youtuber i
guess is because
i i guess that's what's like what i
search for in media which is not just to
be entertained but like this connection
with
a person and a creator and that's why i
try to make content and uh
and i don't know what i i don't know
where to go from there but uh that was
coming to my ted talk thank you for
coming to my ted talk wow i mean that's
like i guess i guess this is where you
go from when from talking about people
dying from cancer right where where did
you go from here
yeah i don't know it's like it's you
know it's tough because like i think
the one like emotion that i personally
feel when it comes to like real life
situations and stuff like that it's like
it's not it's not even like
because you know when you're watching
like media that revolves around like a
death of a character right in any
situation yeah most people think of like
sadness you know like a depression or
you know like some some
like rooted
emotion yeah but like
people who have experienced at least for
me when i experience like a real death
that happened like yeah you don't you
don't feel anything like it's like you
you feel empty yeah yeah i think this
feeling of emptiness
is
extremely difficult to portray in
fiction yeah because it's like how do
you
how do you try to show or evoke
an emotion that is not an emotion yeah
yeah you know and it's like because
because i remember like when when one
when one of my friends from high school
he he unfortunately passed away very
like you know suddenly um from from an
illness right um
you know i had never experienced that
like that was like the first time i had
experienced death
in a close like a real death in a close
vicinity yeah um
and like it was so weird because you
know
media and you know people who haven't
experienced that would lead you to
believe that like you know you go to a
funeral yeah and everyone's crying yeah
you know it's like instantly everyone's
sad but and i thought i was the weird
one
because i didn't cry at his funeral
and i was like am i weird am i being
desensitized like you know like i should
be sad i should be crying i should be
grieving you know all that kind of stuff
and not to say that i wasn't yeah but
like i think
because i'd never experienced anything
like that before that's when i realized
i was like oh
i'm feeling empty yeah because that
because you know it's like it's it's
beyond sadness it's beyond grief and
like it was almost like this weird thing
where like
i didn't start crying
about his death until i got home
that was and that's and that's when it
like hit that was the exact same
experience i had with my grandma as well
yeah like at the funeral i just i was
just like am i broken am i'm a broken
human being
i feel nothing yeah it's like i should
be crying right now right like you hear
back on like you know i was hearing back
on my friend's life and like you know
hearing speeches from my my classmates
and whatnot and i was just like
why am i not crying yeah am i am i weird
yeah
and then it's like
you grieve everyone's sad
and then i went home and i i remember
like i
i like i went into my room and i i lay
on the bed and then i just broke down
crying yeah and it's like oh that's what
that feeling is and it's like i don't i
personally have never seen a piece of
fiction that can properly evoke that
emotion right like it's
i don't know it's weird to say like it's
it's not like it's faking an emotion or
anything like that when it comes to
fiction but it's like it's not
i wouldn't say it's like it's not the
correct emotion yeah i feel and i think
that's just because it's just so
incredibly difficult to show that real
emotion especially when it's with a
bunch of characters that you know you
didn't spend your entire [ __ ] high
school life with right like yeah exactly
so like
personal question
what's the most you've ever cried to
like a piece of fiction
at all the most yeah probably the second
half of planet after story like the last
like six episodes i was like continue
like i was like
like episode like you know
14 15 i'm obviously not gonna spoil it
yeah episode like around like episode 14
15 of planet after story like something
happens yeah and it's like
you break down crying and you think to
yourself
okay it's all out of my system yeah and
then the next episode starts and it's
just like [ __ ] man
why
and then it's just that yeah for the
rest of the episodes until it's over and
you're just a [ __ ] mess i just cried
everything there's a lot of future stuff
that hasn't even said i cried like what
but i like this becky would be fighting
in my hurricane and i'll start crying
[Laughter]
it depends on my mood right yeah yeah
yeah sometimes i'm like a [ __ ] rock
and it's like it could be like the worst
thing on earth yeah
it's really weird because i've found
myself and i think i i think this is
healthy because i've found myself
more easily crying towards pieces of
media and fictional pieces of media now
than i did like uh like five yeah yeah
five five years ago everything yeah and
i think like the thing like
the one that broke the candles back was
like an ohana i'm like
i cried a lot
i think before anahana i don't think i
had ever cried watching
an anime yeah
i'm trying to think for me it was weird
it's like very early on when i was
watching a lot of anime like yeah
because i think i first cried at clan ad
and then it was just like a chain
reaction of like and then i watched
anahana and then i watched air and then
i watched all these shows that made you
cry yeah yeah and then for a while i had
this blank period where you exhausted
yourself maybe yeah and then the one the
work the one that broke the cameras back
for me was makia
machia
yeah
but like i didn't cry like there was so
many like sad shows that people were
like right like i didn't cry at the end
of uh your life in april even though a
lot of people did i didn't either yeah i
don't know that i was like am i weird
for thinking that am i just like
overexposed to this kind of media and
then i and then i watch makia on a
[ __ ] plane tiny screen
like three pixels and i was like and
then the ending to that just like
destroyed me and i was like why is it
this one that made me cry after all this
it's weird because before like i would
any time i would cry just cry towards
something that thing would be like
really really [ __ ] special to break
down the brick wall that i am but
nowadays
known as dance emotions exactly but
nowadays because i cry way more easily i
don't know it's weird sometimes i have
like empty cries where i cry and i'm
just like it's over and then i feel
nothing it's just like i don't know it's
weird like i i'm like i cry and i feel
amazing
yeah right it's just like
like i went to mcdonald's the other day
and i was like why did i do this i cried
i [ __ ] cried to demon slayer and i
was like why what what i get it i get it
i get it
i like the moment i feel sad i'm just
like
i just i just get it over with i just
gotta do it
have you ever had those cries though
where it doesn't feel like you've
released
wait you just feel shittier yeah do you
want to talk about my edging with tears
not edgy
climax with tears no no there's those
times where you know you'd watch
something really sad and then you just
like let the emotions out and then after
your tears have subsided you're just
like oh all right i'm glad that's out
you know i feel good like all my
emotions all my emotional bases out and
then there are some times where you
would start crying and then once the
tears have subsided you just like
man i'm now more sad than i was before
when i was like 15 with breakups i'd cry
i feel worse oh yeah yeah why did she
leave me
like even if i wasn't you know because
you know sometimes when you're like 10
you didn't really understand what's
going on yeah and then maybe when you
get older you're like 15 16 and it's
like oh it's this person that you barely
ever met have to yeah because you're all
connected you know i wouldn't i wouldn't
know them so i wasn't like sad but i
would just get i would just like cry
because i'm like why is everyone crying
this is so sad
you cry because everyone around yeah
because if everyone else is crying
around me i'm like [ __ ] well i gotta do
it now mm-hmm
like mark zuckerberg yeah but like i
said like
this is human emotion i must cry now
sad.exe oh
it's certainly about being around people
who like when a room is filled like sad
energy which makes me get like that yeah
that depends for me right because it's
like say for example like the demon
slayer movie everyone was crying like
[ __ ] crazy at the end of that and i'm
looking around like oh oh it's now i
have to cry now
i can't get the tears out
like to me if if i i cannot cry
to a piece of media if there's someone
else in the room like there's there's
there is a i can't show the mainland
sydney as well oh sydney as well
especially
oh baby man you won luke
no no because because like 10 minutes
before the tears even start forming in
my eyes she's bawling her eyes out
already she's sydney you're on cleanup
duty yeah yeah sydney is so emotionally
receptive yeah that like she will start
crying five minutes before the sad
moments happen and she'll be like in
tears oh my god
yeah like
yeah because um yeah if i'm watching
with sydney i am on emotional cleanup
duty i'm like yes it's okay baby don't
worry like i'm i'm like baby like i i
didn't even get my point like i i didn't
even like yeah i guess i guess you can't
really be like oh baby are you okay
give me a second
you've heard about relationships where
the guy comes too fast and then it ruins
it what another one who cries to you
i can't get my tears in she's already
decided it's over before i've even
started yeah because like i remember
because uh i remember because like your
name uh i cried like a [ __ ] baby the
first time i watched your name and it
wasn't even because it was
sad your name was to me the reason is
one of my favorite anime films is
because to me it's like the perfect
cinema experience where yeah there are
so many things happening on screen that
there's like so many
emotions um
that i just get so absorbed that my body
doesn't know how to react other than
just crying some sometimes i get
emotional and i don't know what to do
with it and i cry that's like an
overwhelm cry yeah it's like it's like
an overwhelming music normally does that
for me yeah yeah he's like like an e key
i don't know
right yeah
it's always the music first black parade
yeah
what is the music the music will make me
cry
i don't know why i tear off whenever i
[ __ ] hear you say around but like
you're screaming yeah yeah why what's
going on yeah i don't really it's like
it's like i've been programmed to like a
certain tune i'm like
it's like pablo yeah yeah i i literally
like yeah
and so i remember i i remember the
second time uh because the first time i
went by myself uh sorry mark zuckerberg
by the way
i know you don't really like these
segments i know you can't relate to this
so the first time i went by myself um
and the second time i was like sydney
you've got to see his films [ __ ]
[ __ ] amazing film better come see
with me and i remember it was the moment
just before rad wimps start playing and
that that is that is my that is the
moment why i start crying i remember i
remember i remember sitting in this film
and uh it was the second time i was
getting as emotional i was getting guys
into i was like getting absorbed i'm
like
it's coming it's coming red ones are
about to play and then like unlike a
minute before like they start playing
i'm just
saying like next to me i'm like oh god
and it's like it just took me out i'm
like
i mean it of course it's sydney balling
her eyes out but uh yeah that's that's
why that's why as much as i love sydney
some if i'm watching a sad thing
if i want to have an emotional release i
cannot watch you with her
i'm like silly can you stop being
emotional for one second did you watch
his new movie
his uh weathering our weathering with
you
yeah whether
yes
i
thought bell was okay
it was
did you say it was mid
okay here's i
watched it by the way oh i haven't seen
it yet what did you think of it
okay did you watch it in cinemas no
okay i feel like that's a movie you have
to experience in cinemas because
everyone everyone i've talked to who has
seen belle right they've talked about
how it's like a [ __ ] incredible
cinema experience with like the sound
and the music and like you there there
are definitely scenes in bellwood i'm
like i get that this it feels like
especially with like the musical scenes
the musical numbers it feels like these
scenes were made
to be experienced in a theater with like
with like the surround sound and
everything um in terms of the plots and
everything else it was not his greatest
movie in my opinion was it one of those
movies though that it was like cry bait
yeah
so it's like so it was like the yeah
because because that's what i felt like
you didn't earn it right but that's the
thing is like it's like sometimes it's
so weird with fiction that is like
obvious cry bait yeah where it's like
sometimes it's like yes i will buy into
the crybait very happily thank you very
much and then there are all the times
where it's like okay you don't have to
push this in my face this much like i'll
cry when i want to cry yeah i can cry
they have a digital world in this show
and a movie sorry and i just i just
wasn't invested in this world i just
didn't think it was like yeah i couldn't
see it being a thing or yeah why people
would care mm-hmm
because it was like we're just gonna
make um online world where you can be
anything except you can't and avatar's
chosen for you and also yeah there seems
to be like a class system where
some people are more important than
others in this world why does that just
sound like someone and i was like i was
like this is just exactly something
yeah
i was like how do you know it's a whole
set of moments he's made the same movie
again yeah with beauty and the beast
this time yeah it was beauty and the
beast that's what i was also like what's
this
i wasn't i was okay yeah it was it was
it was okay
i i agree with you
you know what uh i watched in the cinema
what the batman oh how was it very very
good really have you watched it again no
no was it three hours yes okay and i
loved it how was rob wood pattinson in
that delightful just a tree yeah what a
great guy what a great guy what a what a
vlog
okay i saw him the other day it was like
it was like uh 2010 it was like women
like fawning over rob pattinson yeah
like 20 20 men fawning over roller
patterns yeah it's so true dude hell
yeah it's good it's a good movie that's
a good movie is it a good movie or is it
a good batman movie ah
i think it's not that much of a batman
movie really it's because i i'd give it
an 8.5
because i'm like i'm like one of i'm
like one of the weird people who really
don't give that much of a [ __ ] about
batman i don't know to me to me it's
just i really like this portrayal by by
rob patterson yeah and i thought is it
like more like
is it kind of more like on like the like
joker side
of like storytelling or is it more like
a batman
the scale that we're going with i guess
it would lean more towards the joker's
side okay
but i wouldn't i wouldn't compare it to
the joker either it's more like
they clearly want to tell
batman as a character through this kind
of
somewhat realistic lens of like if
batman was a real person yeah he would
be a [ __ ] weirdo like more like a
human drama side of things well it's
yeah it's a detective movie but also you
know they don't shy away from showing
batman as being
having a lot of issues yeah yeah but the
man's got problems yeah yeah you know
and um more money more problems yeah
dude and uh i liked the villain i
thought it was pretty good the riddler
this time oh oh [ __ ] i thought they did
a good really a really interesting take
on the riddler that i liked um
i just had fun like i was i was there
for three hours maybe towards the end i
felt like i could have hurried up a
little bit yeah but overall i wasn't
bored i really enjoyed it i had a great
time i'm interested to see what riddler
is like in that a movie of that caliber
right because to me the riddler is jim
carrey
it's literally the opposite it is
opposite okay
yeah i think you i think you'd both like
it if you watched it i'm sure i would
yeah and uh it's a great cinema
experience okay it was [ __ ]
the thing that's always wondered me
about the riddler is how the [ __ ] would
that work in the age of google you know
like the rhythm comes up with like a
riddle or something and batman's like
hold on a second okay i got the answer
now
like the one youtube short that he like
watched the other day and he's just like
i remember that one i know the answer to
that one [ __ ] i i would i would look it
up i would show you on tick tock but
it's the algorithm's so [ __ ] the only
issue with my with the movie is that i
wish robert pattinson was just out of
the costume more he's just so good does
he does he do like the gravelly like
oh yeah he does yeah oh okay he's pretty
good at it okay he's just really good at
doing voices in general actually he's
just a good actor he's a good actor
right definitely i watched i watched
good time again after i was like you
gotta watch good time it's so good
please watch good time it's so good this
episode is sponsored by harry's as you
guys know from all the other harry's
address we've done i use harry's it's
the only razor i use when i want to
shave my face it's an eraser i trust
that actually does a clean shave even
after the first few times you've used it
unlike the other razors that i've used
in the past so much so that when i went
to the uk i bought a suitcase full of
harris back to japan because you can't
get it here and new customers can redeem
harry's trial set for just three dollars
when you go to harrys.com
harry's believes you shouldn't have to
choose between a close comfortable shave
and a fair price so they give you both
in fact harry's blades are designed to
stay sharp longer in a recent study guys
who shave four times a week said their
eighth shave was as smooth as their
first what are you waiting for harry's
is giving their best offers to you guys
the listeners and viewers of this show
new harry's customers can redeem a
starter set you get a five blade razor a
weighted handle foaming shave gel with
alloy and a travel cover to protect your
blades when you're on the go that's a
thirteen dollar value for just three
dollars there's truly never been a
better time to try harry's gone go to
harry's dot com trash taste to try
harry's today sorry dallas
because i can't think of
has there ever been a batman that i
thought was interesting because before
the okay i feel like before the dark
knight rises batman just had a like had
like an awful streak of just bad movies
and that just made his dc in general
yeah
you know you don't like the george
clooney batman well with the [ __ ]
back credit card and the [ __ ] bat
nipples
even the best thing about that was
[ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger as uh mr
freeze
nice to meet you
yeah i i just feel like for the longest
time batman was just either a boring or
comical character to me and the most
interesting characters were the villains
of batman and yeah yeah the only time i
thought batman was an interesting
character was actually during the
animated series
um like that was like that was that was
peak batman for me yeah yeah definitely
have you have you seen the animator
series yeah i love the animation how
does this compare to like the animated
series because that to me that that is
good batman it's a different experience
though entirely i feel like it's hard to
compare them both when they're both
trying to do wildly different things
right
i think
but that's also so good because mark
hamill's the joker in that is amazing
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't know i i don't feel comfortable
comparing it almost i feel like it's not
an orange it's not a fair fight i think
you should just watch it you won't
regret it
just watch conclusion watch it genuinely
like it's definitely like i said
this is just this is just connor talking
about media in general
kind of sell me on it
just watch it no there's a lot of stuff
i'll tell you not to watch i don't think
it's worth your time this however is
worth your time did you play the batman
arkham games as well i loved the batman
arkham asylum game dude i got a story
based game that was played it's hardly
story the combat was fun and punching
and exploring stuff that's true i don't
know what the story was i know joker was
[Music]
[Laughter]
god damn it i thought we had one thing
in goblin for once when he's got goopy
gamer yeah i liked it and there was also
the combat trials that [ __ ] was fun as
[ __ ] you did the combat trials because i
was like i was like a i was addicted to
getting all the achievements [ __ ]
those side stories well no so so i i was
obsessed with gamer score
that's the like that's like the last
thing i do like if
i hate it when there is like a [ __ ]
uh when there's a point in the game
where you can like do a trial for the
combat or one of the game mechanics i'm
like get this [ __ ] out of my face i
don't know me too me too yeah okay
unless there's achievements
okay so you're an achievement
i was i wasn't ashamed so here's what
happened right um when i first got my
xbox and i discovered these cheaper
things i thought oh that's pretty that's
pretty cool that's a pretty cool thing
to stride towards and then my friend was
an achievement hunter
and i i was like i want to be better
than him at this
and so i was like well i'm gonna start
doing it and then i'm kind of addicted
to it and i would like i would research
games that were easy to get all of the
achievements on yeah and then buy them
and and do them just to get the
achievement score yeah i had like
60 000 gamer score or something you
could only get about a thousand a game
normally yeah so i had but you got dlc
for some stuff as well
i i bought lost the game
like this tv show lost specifically
because you could get all the
achievements in like two hours really
yeah i don't know what happened
i was absolutely addicted to getting
these achievements and arkham asylum was
one of them i got 100 on and it's really
hard because you had to do one of the
trials and maintain a combo of like 100
or something i can't remember what it
was a lot of people also had to like
collect all like the all the riddler
trophies or the [ __ ] riddler did all
of that and there was also like you had
to do all the stealth missions perfectly
as well yeah or something like that i
can't remember exactly i remember it was
really hard getting all the achievements
but that was such a good game i didn't
mind doing it when's the last time you
did that then
achievement collectors yeah yeah since i
was like oh 1890 when i went to
university i had less time kind of
realized that like wasn't that fun
it's not fun
it's not fun i have i had gotten one of
the hardest achievements uh on xbox
right which is like um
staying alive on um dead rising oh for
seven days straight yeah yeah you did
that no not that one it was another dead
rising one not the seven-day one what
makes it happen
that's on the first game right that's
dead rising one yes i've done all of
them on dead rising too oh [ __ ] which is
i think no they have like kill one
million zombies or something right
stupid right sorry another three days
one my mom would have yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
you had to be
the that one was you had to be alive in
like hardcore dead rising endless for
seven real days like in the real world
how did you get that what was the other
thing you have to go and shift surely
yeah yeah what was the one i did on all
of them on dead rising 2 are really hard
i know that took so long
and that's just like a difficult game
yeah there's some games that you know
this i oh
maybe this is why i hate jrpgs jrpgs
always had the hardest achievements yeah
they did the hands the most
and they had the most cruelest ones
where like get this item that if you
miss it you can't go back and get it
[ __ ] you so that's i think that that
that is what genuinely stopped me from
ever buying a jrpg
because like people have to be
psychopaths like you do 100 jrpgs you do
whereas i'm looking at you joe
how many times did you have to like play
persona 5 before you 100
like six times exactly but i also 100 at
a final fantasy 7 remake as well oh my
god well that one's not too bad i guess
that's not too bad yeah because i i feel
like that's like a third of like the
original game yeah exactly exactly i
wouldn't dare do it with the original oh
no no no [ __ ] that like they've i feel
like they've become a lot more
accommodating in these modern times
compared to like ogj rpg games where
they assume that that's the only game
you're playing for the entire year yeah
they just assume that's the only game
you have on that console
i'm just going to last you the inside
exact time i'm trying to find my xbox
profile so i can see what i've done i
think it's
this one isn't the hardest uh xbox
achievement the [ __ ] mega man 9 one
what's that what's that one it's the one
where you have to beat the entire game
without getting hit a single time
which is oh so that's just a no-hit run
but an actual achievement yeah which if
you've played any mega man game is
practical no um what's the game uh one
of the tom clancy games had an
achievement for being the number one
ranked player in the world oh yeah yeah
yeah no joke
i remember i remember i think i saw like
a watch mojo video a long time ago which
is like the top 10 hardest xbox i was
like top 10 list of games i'm never
going to buy and one of them one of my
already owned because like gears of war
yeah it was like you had to get
uh like 100 000 online kills yeah in the
first game but like no one was playing
the first game after like the third one
came out how would that even be possible
i think how much you don't have to do
100 000 matches with your mates right
now it's kills so you have to be
averaging like [ __ ] hundreds it's
ridiculous yeah
and gears of war is not an easy game to
get kills in yeah so it's it's very
difficult um i can find this i can find
it
all right i've i've got the list of all
of these some of these games are just
[ __ ] stupid i said i have 51 000
gamer score on xbox right
that's like what 50 yeah games 45 i've
every single cod game i have every
single achievement every single every
single halo game i have every single
achievement except for the newer ones
like uh halo wars 2 and
halo hello infinite i have all of them i
had i did all of the i don't know did
you ever do halo there was there was
those challenges where you had to like
do certain things without dying like the
skull ones did all of those i only
played one i've only played halo 1 and
halo 3. i didn't play halo 2. i got
every single achievement in blue dragon
which i remember the dragon yeah the
jrpg yeah oh [ __ ] um yeah i i remember
you were talking about yeah yeah right
yeah yeah yeah i think um what's this
one what's oh
most rare what's the rarest one head
trauma
uh
every type of melee weapon
that's so weird there's there's like
rare it's just a lot in dead rising yeah
everything is a weapon i've killed yeah
okay some of these are like really low
uh some funny games i've done doritos
crash course too
what are all of the achievements on
doritos crashed why would you buy that
game it was free no the other question
is why is there two of them yeah it was
really popular i've got all the
achievements on red dead i think that
wasn't too hard um what else have i done
what weird games these so like would you
basically do nothing would you basically
do nothing until you 100 of these games
yeah i've played south park games i've
played the south park tower defense game
lost i have terminator salvation which i
think i got because that was easy but
then it turned out to be really [ __ ]
hard
um
what's weird what other games do i have
here god most of these are called an
assassin's creed
uh i don't even know what that is i
didn't even do that one that must have
been too hard welcome wait hold on what
was the one after that guacamelee super
turbo champion dude that was a good game
dude that's
melee
and then other games i couldn't do them
all quite a lot of games actually a lot
of the gears of wars ones were just like
[ __ ] uh yeah
forza
destiny
[ __ ] dude i played some weird ass games
what's wrong with me well i think as a
kid you just played any game that you
could get your hands on
yeah and now they're like
fifa of course of course
fitness
i i
i don't know why fifo nine i got all the
achievements on halo wars which one of
them included game to the highest rank
which takes like an absurd amount of
hours
it's a stupid amount of time
yeah yeah i mean i've seen that i don't
think i've ever got addicted to a game
that much that i wanted to 100 it um no
way
because i think the closest i've come
actually um surprisingly is tales of a
rise like
which was which was last year oh oh [ __ ]
it's the first time where i actually
did the fishing mini game because you
know how every game has a fishing mini
game i was like what what is the f who's
[ __ ] what [ __ ] loser plays the
fishing mini game yeah and i'm like this
is actually pretty [ __ ] damn fun
collecting all the fish um but yeah i
mean recently i've been playing horizon
forbidden west i'm like the one [ __ ]
person because everyone's playing elden
ring right now i'm like i'll get to
elden ring eventually after i finish
horizon forbidden west um
and yeah i mean it's is there a fishing
mini game in that one as well
i don't think there is
i was like oh my god i wish
ring i think so i'm i don't know we're
we're not like dark souls or like souls
born
what do you think that's fishing yeah in
an ideal world
we need a twitter account to be like yes
you can fish in hilton i feel like it's
just every jrpg right there you can fish
yeah yeah
it's like a staple i don't know how that
why did i become a trope why because
because japanese people love fishing
yeah do they they love fish
okay they love eating fish that doesn't
matter they don't like catching it
though yeah a nation of fishermen
by this by the same logic should we you
know ask brits should you love fishing
because uh we're we're a [ __ ] island
nation as well right
[ __ ] we don't eat fish we're [ __ ]
idiots
you got fish and chips that's it we eat
cod we won fish and like salmon if
you're rich
yeah why why is that why is that not
only why is there a fishing mini game in
every jrpg but why is that 99 of them
have no effect on the main story
whatsoever it'd be pretty [ __ ] if you're
fighting sephiroth and you're about to
fight him and he's like sorry you
haven't collected all of the 19
different species of fish you are not
ready to face me it's like well get one
i guess i guess that would be weird i
think i would i want a jrpg where you're
actually rewarded at the final boss that
they're like the mob is like you've
you've done the fishing mini game
how did you know that sea bream scales
were my weakness
they start with like half health
i know some people who are like deadly
addicted to like every fishing mini game
in jrpgs i mean allen is that guy allen
is that guy who boots up final fantasy
and then he spends like the first 10
hours on the mini fishing mini game and
then after he gets bored of that then he
actually goes play the game alan's like
alan's that guy who actually does the
mahjong mini game in yakuza
because let's be real every yakuza
player is like don't mess with us we
don't know how to play mahjong because
no one [ __ ] does that mean he came
into the arc of the games
well isn't like the minigames the main
game in yeah
exactly
yeah except the minigame because no one
knows how to follow that's what that is
until you come along and play and then
i'm like let me show you let me show you
how to do it yeah how's your mahjong
coming along jerry really good my
addiction is growing you're speed
running old asian man yeah i am i am i i
went to a mahjong paula for the first
time the other day um
it's really [ __ ] fun i mean like
you know i think that the the general
like stereotype of like a major parlor
is like it's [ __ ] dark it's you know
like smoke is everywhere like basically
[ __ ]
right yeah yeah but like i walk in and
there's i've never seen that many lights
on in one room like i came in i was like
oh [ __ ]
it's so bright and like no one's smoking
in there like a lot of really young
people as well like there was maybe like
two tables that had you know older
gentlemen and everyone else was like
around our age was it all men no
surprisingly like half of them i'd say
like half maybe 40 were were ladies
there were like a couple of tables where
was just four ladies just like sitting
around right um but yeah i went in uh my
i went with like one of my childhood
friends uh because he's been getting
into mahjong as well and he was like oh
we're gonna go to this one uh in ebisu
yeah and i was like why this one in
particular and he's like oh the the uh
the fried rice here is [ __ ] lit
and i was like so we're gonna go play
mahjong are we gonna go for the fries
with the yeah you can order food there
and dude to be honest probably some of
the best fried rice i've had wow in
japan nice while playing mahjong i
believe it it feels like the kind of
place where you get
a weirdly good meal yeah well i wonder
where did mahjong get this image of it
being like a game for old guys or old
people because it's always old people
playing it on like the street like
betting
normally is it i never see that like
normally like my my entire
my entire image of mahjong comes from
media basically because i've before like
before moving to japan i'd never
i guess i'd never seen anyone play
mahjong i i know you're getting this
right pov you're watching a movie right
it's a spy movie let's say a spy movie
or any kind of movie
they're undercover in uh
uh indonesia let's say yeah
do they play major in indonesia yeah
southeast asia is pretty much right so
they're playing
you know let's say they're in indonesia
on a mission yeah oh no their cover's
been blown we've got to start running
through buildings yeah charging the one
building oh it's a it's a food store
chicken everywhere run into the next
room oh god it's a bunch of old people
playing
you've seen this scene like 500 times
every year like because it's always just
old people in a smoky room playing
mahjong
they keep running through it's always
there always and then they always do
some kind of corny
right as they're running out here well
it's either that or it's like an old
like distinct asian shouting yeah it's
almost like an old kung fu movie yeah
and you get into like bad guys lair yeah
what's he doing he's sitting down
playing mahjong with his fellow with his
guys asserting dominance right those
that's that's like the image i have of
mahjong like in that that
dark smokey room and everything like
that well it's like i feel like it's
like the poker of japan or like poker of
asia really yeah definitely the kind of
game where gambling's not legal but me
and the boys can have a little wager or
two yeah
yeah have you guys ever played bridge
before uh no i'm not 90. yeah exactly
i've heard of that game what is that
that's that's a game which i don't know
what card game
it is a card game um i don't know what
the image is i don't know if it's like
famous outside of the uk or anything
like that oh yeah it's famous in the us
and again for being the thing that
people play and all people play it right
yeah and like i remember i think it was
in like high school or something um one
of our teachers
for like uh for like this uh for like
you know you know you have a free period
sometimes and it's the end of term you
can do whatever you like so this teacher
decided to teach us bridge um just teach
us the rules and i got like i got like
addicted at a point where i'd like
joined the bridge club yes i i was [ __ ]
i was that kid who actually joined the
bridge club because like it was he had
this image of like mahjong being what
old retired people play in retirement
homes but like it is fun as [ __ ] right
like it's it's kind of similar to
mahjong in a sense where you get given a
bunch of you know it it is it is kind of
like poker where it is
luck based but it's also skilled skill
based but what i found most interesting
to bridge is that it's it's a team game
right so the basic concept is before
each game you have a partner who sits
like opposite you right
and you basically have to make a bet
on
how many
how many points you'd be able to get in
the hand you're about to play so you're
like kind of communicating with your
partner and communicating and trying to
like
assess what everyone what everyone has
uh by the bets that they're placing and
i thought that was like that i think
that's like super genius it's basically
like uno but before the uno game starts
you have to try and guess what everyone
else has you're working in a team
and uh yeah like
like to me i wanted to talk about it
because like bridge has this image of
being a boring game that all people play
but i think it's like interesting as
[ __ ] and i haven't played bridge since i
was in school uh when i was in bridge
club but yeah i got super addicted for a
while because i i think it's a genuinely
fun game yeah it's the same with marjon
right i was like i i you know before i
started playing it i was like nah i'm
not gonna get into this like this is
what my grandma was into yeah yeah it's
like but then when you actually start
playing you realize just how like
intricate it is and it's not just like a
[ __ ] you know well i don't think it
was an old people thing i think it was
like a really complicated thing yeah but
it's it's interesting though how even
something like mahjong which is a very
complicated like deep you know and very
like you know
mind intensive game yeah is associated
with all people yeah yeah if you look at
like the pro scene for example like most
people are like dudes and chicks
yeah yeah i mean it's like you know it's
like
chess in the parks in new york yeah all
the old dudes are playing it but yeah
it's the young people here it's a pr
thing right when are we going to get
like you know a twitch camera everything
everything's a branding issue yeah
because i i i can't be fixed with a bit
of branding and people remember like
like literally just two years ago where
chess had the same thing and then
suddenly chess had his [ __ ] second
renaissance uh with the explosion it's
had on twitch and now it's seen as like
this cool thing though is next
i'm gonna call it mahjong is next you
know you know what i want to learn
tubers are already on that [ __ ] yeah
yeah that that's the secret we need to
get the v tubers to all start playing
the japanese the japanese youtubers have
been on that [ __ ] for so long yeah right
yeah i think yeah weirdly chess is one
of those sports where
when you look at it on paper it
shouldn't be a spectator sport yeah like
everything about it makes it
almost a bad spectator sport there's
long gaps in between moves yeah it's not
that
engaging
story lines are a little harder to you
know get across
and it's visually not that exciting it's
uh you look at a board for like 15
minutes at a time if you're lucky
they'll make a move every 15 minutes
world championship but somehow i think
just out of pure
like being a very solid and ubiquitous
game it's managed to somehow carve a
good niche and a pretty strong one yeah
but also chess has also had great
success by having the branding of being
the smart man scared well the smartest
of smarts play chairs i think the
problem with chess as a spectator sport
is that um with a lot of sports right
you
you look at the higher level players you
look at you know like you know
traditional sports like football
basketball maybe even like league or
whatever and you can like you can even
even as a normal person you can
appreciate the skill being shown you see
someone doing a speed run of mario 64 or
something you're like damn those are
some no words needed yeah no one is
needed that's [ __ ] speaks for itself
but like me watching
a high-level chess game like the chess
world championships it's like i've never
understood the feeling of that side
character in dragon ball z where like
the character explains the moves yeah
yeah no you know where we're like where
like the main characters are following
the fight perfectly and you just see
like you just see nothing like that this
is me watching high level chess you know
that's why i think chess has gotten
really good in recent years at having
the the kind of what a lot of esports
are doing and what traditional sports
are doing for a long time where one of
them is the one that's saying what's
going on yeah and one of them's helping
add color and break it down and yeah
like explain it and chess has been
really good at that recently because i
mean i like watching the world
championships but even then
there are periods where nothing happens
for 20 minutes and it's like
[ __ ] to do like come on like
yeah sometimes i get like i i i get um
recommended like a clip of magnus
carlsen streaming or something like that
and it's just like an out of context
clip of like this [ __ ] 500 iq move
and then the move happens and i don't
even know it's happened yeah because it
was like five moves ago that he reacted
to it and like he and like i remember i
think one of the funniest videos i've
seen it's just like i can't remember the
exact video but it's uh it's a
it's a parody video of someone
commentating on a magnus carlsen stream
and it's just like a normal person
commenting on his stream and it's just
like and magnus carson leaves his knight
hanging is he going to take it is the
opponent going to take it no he doesn't
take it he doesn't take the free knight
oh now he's left his queen hanging is he
is he going to take the queen magnus the
queen is right there no he doesn't take
the queen and uh and he looks like he's
in an awful position right now and he
resigns magnus carlsen resides i don't
know what's going on and it's just it's
it's it's it's exactly how i feel
watching
watching a high level chess game when
i'm just like there is a hanging queen
right there why is magnus castle not
taking the hang oh and he just resigned
for no reason um and he scrolls to the
comments section and it's never the top
comment that's explaining what's
happening it's always like buried a few
comments down just be like i can someone
just explain to me what i thought i just
witnessed please
um but yeah i mean like that's why
one
one game i've really want to get into
because it sounds super interesting it
always looks super interesting to me um
but i'm [ __ ] terrified of possibly
getting into is go go seems to me like
that is just like chess is complicated
by itself go
to me even just
even just the concept of go it seems
like what like viewing
a bottomless pit that you cannot see
like you know you can't see the end of
my grandad was in to go and he was like
really good at it and he tried to teach
me when i was in high school and i was
like i don't know what the [ __ ] is
happening
i know you're like i know you're showing
me the ropes like really nicely and
clearly but like
i'm all i'm thinking is oh black and
white stones
all i know is that google documentary
about the ai they built to beat the best
player yeah then i read hikaru ago and i
was like i understand what's happening
no i i i like because i also read
hecarim ago as well i read all of it and
i remember there was a point where they
tried to explain what was going on to
the viewer and i think halfway through
the manga they just stopped yeah they
they just stopped showing the matches
right and they just like i'm not even
going to try and explain it this guy
wins and you see like it's a manga that
that just it bases its hype on of people
off of like character reactions as
opposed to what's going on in the match
i think it's because they just assume
you're like you're you're you're feeling
full you've got it like your 15 volumes
you should know how this works by now
like we're not gonna explain it to you
like i still don't think i understand
how football works and i watched all of
um which mean football sorry american
football oh okay sorry football um i
don't know how football works and i
watched i read all of ice shield 21 i
think i understand
i don't think that's like very you know
like realistic like you're not going to
be like you're not going to be watching
the superman being like oh how he could
have done a devil back ghost there why
didn't he but you know when you're like
watching something you're like i feel
like i should understand how this base
game works yeah i don't baseball is
another one that i've watched stuff
about and i'm like i think i understand
the baseball but i'm not so sure
really baseball's fairly easy to figure
out i i i don't understand when they
swap that much but then again three
strikes right three strikes right and
they swap teams yeah yeah so you get
three goes and then everyone no because
then they all everyone on the field
swaps yeah yeah
oh
yeah yeah so it's not three not three
like throws right it's just no it's not
three strikes
so when you so when you throw in
baseball you can i it can either be a
strike or a ball yeah right and and you
have a you have a strike zone yeah that
you had that pictures have to throw into
yeah i know that i know yeah yeah so
when it's three strikes and that's what
then they're out and when it's three
outs they switch yeah yeah yeah and
they're usually like
never even when i read stuff about it my
baseball just doesn't look fun am i bad
am i wrong baseball's hella fun dude
really yeah i love it i mean there's a
lot of sports that aren't are fun to
play but not fun to watch i feel like it
would be fun to play yeah but not funny
to me that's baseball that's golf
that's cricket sorry indians um
i'm offended
like i have fun playing them but
watching them i kind of fall asleep i
mean i think kind of
same with american football as well
because uh i think my problem with a lot
of american sports growing up with you
know somebody watch you know uh you know
real football um and
a lot of europeans yes i [ __ ] said
yes i [ __ ] said it it's it's the
amount of starting and stopping and the
uh advertisements that go in between
yeah like that's yeah that's yeah that's
what that's what i don't really like
about the nfl on the american football
is like
yeah it's just way too many starts and
stops yeah i'm just like like right as
like when a play is happening and you're
like oh [ __ ] here we go oh they stopped
i i don't understand
this is again for someone who's i i
again i i think i understand how
american football works i don't i'm not
sure entirely you think you understand
how it works i think i understand the
rules right okay but even when i'm i'm
watching it
my my older brother really likes
american football but i'm just thinking
like why would i ever want to watch this
over rugby yeah i'd much rather just
there's no point where i've ever watched
a like american football game and
thought [ __ ] i wish this was rugby
like i think so there's a nipple that i
haven't thought that every single time i
watch american football i'm like i
should wish this was rugby i i think
just because i'm i'm i'm going to be the
american here i'm going i'm going to be
the american st tell me why because i
think i don't know sticking up for
american football um because i think
um even though i just complained about
the stop start i think
the beauty of american football is that
it comes in bursts right and when
when that burst happens i don't think
there's another sport that could really
compete with american football with just
the amount of
the amount of small things happening in
such a short period of time because
there are so many things going on
when when they're in when it's in play
australian football would like to have a
word okay i haven't watched australian
football joey okay
but to me that that is that is the real
strength of american football uh but
it's super intricate especially when you
know you when you have an idea of like
oh that's this plan they're doing all
these different schools that's fun to
watch but it's like it happens so
quickly it happens so quickly and then
by the time you're like oh that was kind
of cool then they're stopped yeah so
that's why i love basketball basketball
is so fun to watch basketball is really
fun basketball's hella fun yeah that's
it's sports that you know have a
constant movement going on right that's
why rugby's so fun because it's like
it's out except if it's like a penalty
or whatever it's just like constantly
moving yeah like to me like oh this is
this is a preference like i as a
spectator sport i do like when the
when the rules are how can i how can i
how can i work this like fluid you know
that's like the offense and defense can
change at any time if if there's if
there's a sport
where you know you have an offensive
team and a defensive team and then they
swap at certain intervals like american
football like um baseball cricket or
whatever then that's like i i like it
when anything can happen when there's
more randomness of like you know someone
you're a mario party yeah basically
what are the items
banana person banana appeals on the
baseball field yeah and then and then
i'll watch
yeah i mean like every sport has to play
the mario baseball game you'd love that
game did they bring out new mario soccer
yeah is there a mario baseball game yeah
on gamecube super mario strikers no
strikers is the softest [ __ ] that's the
football game
oh sluggers oh my god dude that's a
blast in the past bro i i try to get
that game for christmas for so goddamn
long yeah my parents had to like buy it
off some shady chinese website and it
turned up and my parents and i also was
too young i didn't know about region
lock yeah yeah
and with my mom bless her she like tried
so goddamn hard to get a copy of this
game but they never sold it i found
sluggers the other day actually at uh in
akihabara and i bought it and i played
it for the first time since like i was
like 12 and i was like this game's
godlike like
easily the best mario sports game no
strikers was really strikers is good but
i'm just i'm more of a fan of new one
but i'm more a fan of baseball than foot
than soccer so no no football you're
right you're right the first time joey
you're right the first time in soccer
you were right the first time joey it's
soccer i refuse to call soccer football
oh god but anyway that's been this
episode of trash taste so we did talk
about a wide run to a bunch of things
today a random episode yeah very random
episode from wildlife to uh sad boys to
uh back to video games right god i want
to eat a [ __ ] tortoise so bad
god i wish i could have tried that
tortoise man i better what is it with
you an extinct food oh just like his
first thing
was born in like the british empire i
would have been the one guy they were
like [ __ ] don't let him on the [ __ ]
boat dude he's just gonna stop bringing
weird [ __ ] animals to eat
the reason why it hasn't had a genome
there's because of connor cohen
dude i would i would have been like
sorry scientists man it's it you gotta
try it oh wait you can't i ate it all
okay here's the thing like you know
since we're past the era of discovery
where you know and you're adding in
another topic before we end this i i
guess so i guess
since we're past the year of discovery
um i'm jealous of not the people who are
the first to like discover this new land
but imagine like discovering a new
animal and being the first person to
ever taste it
the people who taste it of your type of
people what do you mean well i feel like
you know in australia i'm sure like
aboriginal people had eaten a bunch of
the stuff that was about sure sure yeah
but yeah i guess you would be the first
foreigner to try it yeah yeah yeah i got
it i guess i i i think to me that's way
more exciting than discovering all the
foods that might have tasted good but
the first guy had it thought it tasted
bad so he never yeah but but it's also
like this look like a terrifying element
to it right because you don't like could
you imagine the first person who drank
like cow's milk
yeah like that would have been [ __ ]
terrifying people have been terrifying
or just really weird yeah it's like it's
like oh this weird white [ __ ] just came
out from the tit of a cow yeah i'ma
drink it you know it's like respect i
respect
they love milk and probably just taught
wow
hey if you want to be milked then uh
make sure to go to our page on
patreon.com
also follow us on twitter citizens on
the subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify but uh yeah
anyway that's been trash chase we'll see
you guys next week bye
[Music]
you